brief announcement some people requested
to talk on a one-hour monthly group call
either asking questions or presenting
their ideas to me slash others so a
patreon tier has been opened up for that
purpose the first call will be limited
to around 10 people and it will be june
1st 2022 for the meta field theorist
tier that's patreon.com kurt jymungal
as with all the toe podcasts you can
click on the timestamp in the
description to skip this intro today's
guest is diana walsh posalka diana
pasulka is a professor of religious
studies at the university of north
carolina wilmington and the chair of the
department of philosophy and religion
she's also the author of american cosmos
which explores the connection between
religion and technology while also
disproving the common misconception that
only fringe members of society believe
that the phenomenon has some non-terrain
reality behind it in this episode we
focus heavily on religion and philosophy
a rather technical dive into certain
philosophies as well as how us humans
deal with unexplainable experiences my
name is kirche mungle and i'm a
filmmaker slash podcaster slash person
investigating theories of everything
from a theoretical physics perspective
but as well as understanding the
philosophies of consciousness and what
role consciousness has to fundamental
reality recently there's been a video
released on this channel called a crash
course on theoretical physics which was
the longest time that i've spent on any
single video on this channel if you're
interested in salvator pius's ideas on
quantum gravity or extra dimensions or
what it means when a physicist
quote-unquote sets c to equal one to
equal h-bar then do consider watching
that as it's the lesson that i wish i
had when i was going to university by
the way my background is in mathematical
physics and the math in this video was
aimed at the high school level there are
plenty of myths in physics that are
dispelled there as well as well as
general tips on learning mathematics and
physics feel free to share that to
someone who's interested in physics and
mathematics this work was only able to
be done because of brilliant and the
patrons now with regard to brilliant
they're the sponsor of this episode
brilliant is a website and an app that
has interactive learning experiences
with regard to math science and
engineering they have lessons on
information theory on group theory and
special relativity group theory by the
way is what's being referenced when you
hear that the standard models
quote-unquote internal gauge symmetries
are u1 cross su 2 crosses su 3 and so on
at some point soon i'll be speaking to
chiara marletto on constructor theory
and that is heavily predicated on
information theory and so i took
brilliance course and it made it
extremely lucid why the formula for
entropy is the way that it is visit
brilliant.org toe to get 20 off the
annual subscription i recommend you
don't stop before at least four lessons
and i think you'll be greatly surprised
at the ease at which you now can
comprehend subjects you previously had a
difficult time grocking now if you enjoy
witnessing and engaging in real time
conversation with others on the topics
of consciousness psychology physics
religion then check out the description
for a link to the theories of everything
discord and subreddit there's also a
link to the patreon that is
patreon.com if you'd like to support
this podcast as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reason that i'm
able to put out videos of this quality
and this depth such as the crash course
on theoretical physics as this is what
i'm now able to do full time thanks to
your support
thank you and enjoy
professor why don't you go over what
american cosmic is and i believe you
said that you have
changed from being a non-believer in the
quote-unquote phenomenon to taking more
of a stance of an agnostic believer so
what's responsible for that change
sure
so i started the research into this i'm
a professor of religious studies and um
just to give your listeners an
understanding of what we do in religious
studies because a lot of people think
we're like ministers and stuff we're not
so we're academics and scholars and it's
an interdisciplinary field so we come at
religion with um
different tools like art basically
archaeology sociology history you know
whatever we can use to understand
the impact and effects of religion on
populations
and um
my field has been catholic history and
looking at
basically catholic history right um
european catholic history when you say
catholic history here's another thing
that your listeners should know is that
that's huge you know there are billions
of catholics all over the world and so
you know one person can't know all of
that history so we focus as well so
we're really focused generally um i've
been looking at extraordinary
things within catholic history and in
catholic history there are saints who
are said to have levitated
and bilocated and things like that so
i've been looking at that i've been
looking at dogmas in catholic history
how dogmas of religion are formed and
then go away and so these are the things
that i've been doing
almost my whole life and
certainly as a professor
so
after writing a book about the dogma of
purgatory which is a belief in
catholicism which is a place where souls
go after they die they don't go to hell
but they also don't go to heaven so they
go to this place called purgatory where
they purge their sins supposedly and
then you know then um they're one with
god so this is a belief that ran a
practice that was within catholic
history for a long time so i did a
survey of this and
um
you're right i was an atheist with
respect to ufos um never thought of them
never believed in them um i was
as many people were
and i
on the edge of scoffing at people who
said oh i saw a ufo you know it's like
right you really saw a ufo and so
um
so no i never ever thought i would be
doing this kind of study um but what
happened was that in 2011 and 2012 i i
had been finished with this book and
moving on to some new research in
catholic history obviously but what i
had was i had been going through
archives which are really old libraries
of things from like hundreds of years
ago and i'd been putting together
basically reports um catholics have
always taken great notes and they have
records and
um they have chronicles and things like
that from a thousand years ago or more
and so i'd been looking at these
and i was making an uh a note basically
of things that i couldn't really fit
into
basically that were strange in my
opinion i thought what are these things
so we're talking about orbs of light
things that are aerial phenomena um orbs
that that penetrate walls um
you know things that
uh like move like houses in the air you
know these kinds of reports and the
people that were making these reports
today we'd call them like reliable
witnesses you know they were usually
part of the catholic hierarchy they were
nuns or
brothers you know scholars
um people like this mayors of towns what
was it about these reports in particular
that stood out because i'm sure there
are many reports by many religious
people about extraordinary events so was
there something in particular or are you
studying any abnormal aberration from
reality
no at this at this point i was just
focused on what happened to the practice
the catholic doctrine and practice of
purgatory you know prior to the 1960s uh
you could go to any catholic church and
there would be a place where you would
pray for souls in purgatory and that's
just not the case now and in fact if you
asked your friends who are catholic you
know hey what about purgatory they
wouldn't know what you were talking
about so i was looking at what why did
this dogma disappear basically and so
when i was i was looking at these
reports i would come to reports of
basically here's here's one that i had
in my book on purgatory it was in the
1800s and it was this nun in france and
she would continually see
an orb of light come through penetrate
her cell wall where you know she lived
and basically kind of hang out you know
i thought you meant her cell walls
how could she see that oh my gosh this
is truly that would be really weird yeah
no where she was she was in a convent
and so this ball of light would come and
she was afraid of it and she'd tell the
people in her convent and nobody really
believed there first then finally
the mother superior came and stayed the
night in her you know room and and she
saw also so they interpreted this as a
soul from purgatory and then they did it
they prayed it away they tried to pray
it away and so these are the kinds of
reports that i was identifying in all of
these these um you know lots of
different like chronicles you know these
kinds of sources it was unsuccessful
they're praying away was their prayer
unsuccessful and that's a good question
was it it apparently was
so was successful or unsuccessful it
appears to be because there was no more
report okay so i assume that it was
successful
i think
yeah so okay so um yeah
so i had a list of these things
and i didn't include them in my
purgatory book just one or two of them
because i thought well the frameworks
are so strange for you know how people
interpreted these things
and i didn't quite understand what to do
with this big list of of reports
so i was going to move on to another
book
and i happened to show a friend of mine
these reports and i said what do you
think of this stuff and the friend
looked at them and said they look like
steven spielberg movies you know like
ufos and i i thought that's crazy um it
just so happened that there was a
uh in my town there was a ufo conference
so i went to the conference and i
listened to people who had experiences
with aerial phenomena and the
inhabitants of aerial phenomenon
allegedly right and so it sounded so
much like what i've been studying that i
decided to turn my attention to
making kind of like this comparison
which is not you're not supposed to do
in my field but i did it anyway i wanted
to see if there was kind of this
continuity between these reports from
historic you know history back at least
catholic history to today and that's how
i started now of course the book became
completely
different than i had intended um
so
that's how i started now the book itself
what happened when i got into the
research was that i didn't just find out
information about people who had these
experiences i also found out that there
were secret programs that our government
was engaged in this is before it came
out in the new york times and i met them
and i followed them around and they they
actually invited me on you know
excursions like to new mexico uh to find
debris from crash saucers and things
like that i mean it was pretty wacky i
thought it was really strange and i was
still an atheist when i was writing
the book it was until the very end this
took me a few years right it took me
years to get through and we're now in
2022. um in 2019 the book was published
it was done in late 2017
and so how many years is that that's
like you know six years of my life that
i spent
and during that time period i went from
moving from an atheist
and a scoffer
to what the heck is going on here
agnostic
what are beliefs
okay so in our field so beliefs if you
ask a different like if you ask a
philosopher they're going to have a
different definition
but beliefs in our field are basically
practices
uh and behaviors and
expectations
of basically phenomena like events that
are going to happen like i have a belief
that the sun will rise tomorrow
okay now belief beliefs don't actually
they can or they cannot correspond with
what we call objective reality so
tomorrow the sun will most likely rise
and then my belief will be true but it
doesn't necessarily have to be true so
it's like i can have a false belief
so in our field that's how we define
beliefs
so you said that it's practice so some
form of action but also expectations so
the expectation to me sounds cognitive
whereas the other one sounds embodied
and does that mean that one can have a
belief and not know what their belief is
oh definitely you can have unconscious
beliefs
yeah
i'm sure you've heard some people say
this that atheists
at least the well-behaved ones are not
disbelievers in god because they act as
if god exists god implies an ethic which
endows people with uh
inviolable quality with respect to their
life and so on so what do you make of
this claim
about atheism
about atheists are not even though they
can proclaim atheism that they don't
necessarily believe it in the sense that
their actions belie their words
okay so
all right let's let's first figure out
what we mean by religion okay and theism
and things like that so okay for people
who study religion
when we think of somebody who is say a
well-known atheist like
dawkins all right um
we think that he doesn't actually he's
not had a good religious studies course
right and this is why we think that
because when we start by teaching
undergraduates what religion is we start
by saying what you think first of all
religion is a made-up term okay some
there are some
societies that don't even have a term
for religion okay a lot of indigenous
spiritualities don't even
think about religion so religion is
something that was created
in order to identify
something now
generally the people that created this
term these people came from um european
culture so to them religion looked like
christianity okay so christianity what
are the components of it well you have
like a god and you have um
jesus right this person um and you've
got these sets of beliefs and practices
which by the way are very very different
from one another there are over i
believe there are over 10 000
denominations of christianity so that's
a lot and they look very different from
one another so one of the exercises that
i have in my class is i show students um
a video of an ethiopian
mass which is like a service a church
service and then i show them but i don't
tell them what it is i say look at this
and then i show them another service
it's a southern baptist service and i
say are these two services similar and
they say no they're so different right
one has like incense and chanting and
the other has you know someone's talking
and people kind of praying
and um
and they look very different and so i
say these these are both christian
denominations this is christianity right
here and it's hard for them to believe
because they they look so different so
if we're talking about religion there
are some religions like buddhism that
have no idea of a god right there's no
god like a christian god in buddhism and
even certain denominations of buddhism
they look very different from one
another
zen or chan buddhism looks way different
than thai buddhism theravada buddhism
okay so um all right so the question
that you have is
again let's talk about atheists too
because atheists are different as well
so dawkins has an idea kind of what i
would call a straw man idea of religion
in that it's easy to
look at religion in that way and say
well of course the beliefs are incorrect
and you know there's contradictions all
over the sacred texts and these kinds of
things but that's just that's not even a
a
a definition that we would use of
religion because that's a strong man
representation of religion so this so
the question you're asking me is
atheists are already assuming they're
gonna like wake up the next day and be
alive and they're already assuming these
things that christians would say god or
some religious people religious
traditions would say have been gifts to
humans right like life and that kind of
thing is that what you're asking me i
guess instead of going back to the same
question how about i just play the
atheistic part and say well the atheist
may just say well i'm not believing as
an article of faith that i'm going to
wake up tomorrow i have the evidence
just like you mentioned the sun
yeah yeah i think that's correct i mean
i assume that i'm going to be living
tomorrow as well so i believe that i
think that's a correct
assessment but you have to understand
that i'm also not in it i'm not a person
who's going to advocate belief in
religion
i mean i'm a scholar of religion i'm not
i've i'm not an advocate for religion i
am an advocate though for understanding
what religion is and is not definitely
you know there are fiction there are
fiction-based religions
so there are religions based on movies
and things like that
are those more satirical or those more i
mean there are satirical religions but
there are some serious religions that
are based on star wars
i've met practitioners of jedi yeah
and they don't believe what they're
doing is a form of being facetious
they're actually no they're having fun
nope
nope there are some that do but there
are a lot that don't this this started
in the early 2000s 2002
and i used this as a
basically as a case to show my students
that religion has a big definition right
so we're talking about what's called a
new religious movement
okay
and i used to actually
um think that it was going to go away
and i did think it was you know kind of
the spaghetti monster religion that it
was satirical and i think that it began
that way or it began in separate places
by different people
um but it's definitely a religion it's
definitely a cultural development and it
did not go away
is religion merely a mind virus i'm sure
you've heard that term can it be
explained purely memetically
and deleteriously it's like not one
that's yeah
it's hard to say um i'm still i prom i
promise you i don't know and i'm still
trying to figure it out so i'm still
thinking through it and um i did i have
spoken to some people who are basically
colleagues
and it appears that you know
religion might even predate humans
you know in the sense that
um
proto-hominins
like neanderthals and things like that
when you look at
how they buried each other it appears
that they have some ritualistic like
kind of uh there are some rituals that
were involved that look to be you know
religious when we take the big
definition of religion which i've kind
of talked about so
i don't know i mean i still think that
it's uh an adaptation that we just don't
understand
because you know lots of people said it
was going to go away and that's called
the rationalism thesis you know as
people get more rational religion will
just as a will just go away but there
are more
religious people today than there ever
have been in history so that's obviously
incorrect so there's something that we
need from religion
um that seems that keeps it around
is that rationalism thesis also known as
the secularization thesis or is that a
separate phenomenon no it is it's the
same
yeah it's the same so in that case as
far as i know in the western world
atheism is on the rise it's just in
other parts of the world where it's not
is that correct yes i i believe that's
correct
yeah so then in that case would that not
be a testament to the secularization
thesis because it's saying that in these
more in light i know that this is
eurocentric and and i'm going to get
cancelled but i'm just i'm strong
manning for the sake okay
maybe the rationalists are more likely
to say this but in these more
enlightened societies that's where
atheism takes the foothold and it's more
of the something that's akin to a
religious monarchy that the
religions it's mainly through dominance
and so on so why does the growth of
global religion contradict the
secularization thesis
because to me it sounds like well in
this
thesis is saying that in the spots where
we hold the values of the enlightenment
and so on is where atheism should take
hold all right i think what you're
talking about is a movement called um
where where especially young people um
they basically say that they're not
religious but they might be spiritual
but not religious and these people are
called the nuns and they're called the
nuns they're not n-u-n-s they're
n-o-n-e-s
and they're called that because when
they
tick off the census they put we have no
religion so we have what's your religion
none right so that's what makes them you
know that's why they're called the nuns
okay so this is definitely on the rise
but the thing about this is that to us
in religious studies it actually does
not look secular because those people
engage in yoga okay and they also
believe in ufos right and so when you
scratch the surface of belief in ufos
you see like you know transcendent
beliefs or beliefs and a transcendence
of you know this um
this advanced tech is somehow salvific
right and things like that or on the
other hand it's very bad you know it's
like kind of evil or something like that
so you do see a lot of themes there that
appear to be religious like so i would
contest that the rise of the nuns is
actually a secularization
um
the rise of atheism i think that as you
know
i mean beliefs change
atheism is something that
um
you know i wouldn't ascribe it i
wouldn't say
atheists are de facto more rational than
religious people that's just not right
that's not true
um
so i wouldn't ascribe the rise of
atheism to the rise of
kind of rationality or something like
that because i know a lot of people who
are
not atheists
they're either agnostic or theists and
are very rational
so but i mean it's just not who i know
but it's also you know
um
these are generalizations that i think
require
a lot of
we must we have to be really careful
when we're talking about that but yeah i
don't see that
what's this association between religion
and belief in ufos so for example you
just said an atheist may believe in ufos
and there's a religious like quality
because they believe in a transcendent
or they believe in transcendence okay so
i just see that as it's broadly similar
but i don't see it as being wholly
similar so there must be more analogies
than simply that so why don't you
outline that for the audience and myself
yeah of course okay so when you look at
um
when you look at
religion and you look at
belief in ufos okay so what you see
first of all let's get rid of this idea
that religion has to be exactly like
christianity okay and instead let's look
at religion as a set of beliefs and
practices directed toward that which
looks to be of transforming and
transformative power okay because that's
you know that includes then buddhism and
you know some hinduism and things like
that so other religions other than
jewish christian islam okay so then you
look at people who actually report
seeing or being
um in touch with inhabitants of ufos and
a significant um percentage of them have
a transformative experience after
they've seen one okay they're like wow
that really changed everything for me i
just now know i mean i've talked to so
many now thousands and thousands of
people who have had experiences of
either seeing a ufo or believing somehow
that they're in contact with ufos now
i'm not saying this is
true or false because in my field we
don't actually weigh in
a very few of us weigh in on what you
know trying to say this is a this exists
or this doesn't exist you can prove it
right
right now we just can't prove that
so um
you know it's the same with religion you
can't prove god it exists or doesn't
exist um so we just don't do that we
just look at social effects but we also
identify patterns so
when people so this is what i saw when i
started my work in
looking at people who've seen ufos or
believe that they're in touch with the
inhabitants of ufos like
extraterrestrials it i mean we already
have religions based on ufos okay so we
have nation of islam based on ufo
sighting uh realism based on a ufo
sighting okay so a lot of times people
will have transcendent experiences
either when they see a ufo or after
they've seen the ufo so the transcendent
experience that changes their lives
that's like a religious conversion
because that's you know if you look at
the history of people who have been
converted to religions you'll see that
that's the type of experience that
they're having and then a lot of times
these people have
intense
uh long-term
behavior changes okay where their value
system changes like maybe they were
really about making money you know um
and you know and all of a sudden boom
they have this experience of a ufo and
um that you know these people are called
experiencers by the way people who are
um
people who've seen or
believe they're in conversation with
inhabitants of ufos they're called
experiencers and they've been around for
a long time um but that you know right
now that because of media
and entertainment media
uh people are more inclined to look at
these events like when they see
something like an aerial phenomena you
know they're they're more inclined now
to say if they can't identify it as a
drone or an airplane or something like
that they'll say oh it must be a ufo you
know which is an unidentified flying
object absolutely but then that there's
a whole
group of assumptions that they bring to
that
um that interpretation so we're looking
at interpretive structures that have
changed
and that's why the ufo is now like a
rising what i would call not a religion
although we specifically have ufo
religions i would call it the rise of a
religiosity
what's the definition of religiosity
yeah so religion looks very distinct and
it kind of mimics or looks very similar
to say a traditional religion like
christianity in that you have a person
who has seen a ufo
and then um brings that information to
other people and those people become
converted to that religion let's say
nation of islam or something like that
and then that's a very discreet
uh set of beliefs and practices all
right you're either a nation of islam
person or you're not okay
um but a religiosity
is more like what we see with this uh
spiritual but not religious community
it's a set of beliefs and practices that
people have that they don't have to
ascribe to they don't say
i absolutely believe
in
this person's
idea of what the ufo message is it can
be it can um
it's basically
it's not discrete
it's a uh this dissemination of
the beliefs and practices
is decentralized
there's no centralized belief structure
or institution
and um people get their information
through each other on social media or
through
media like star wars or something like
that right or through documentaries that
are supposed to actually be
um
non-fiction right even new york times
you know where you see the tic tacs and
things like that
so and that's what i call a religiosity
so a lot of people are having their
lives completely
or their let's put it this way that way
they're having their basic truths and
assumptions about reality shifted
because of belief in extraterrestrials
and that's that's what i see and you
also mentioned the phrase that there's a
transformative experience where they
radically alter their beliefs or their
outlook on life afterward i believe you
said that was an element it's not a
surprising criteria but it's a necessary
one
i don't know if it's a necessary one but
it's it's a necessary well okay there
are different you know um there are
different varieties of belief in ets and
ufos so some people believe that they
were here in the past and maybe seeded
civilization actually dawkins has a
video out there if you youtube it you
know doc and zt where he basically
suggests something like that
um or that someday in the future maybe
you know we'll be in contact with them
or something like that or that they're
out there but we'll just never be in
contact with them because the universe
is just you know huge
um
or they're in contact with us now okay
so these are different ways that people
believe
in
ufos and ets are those people who
believe in the transformative experience
of psychedelics somehow religious even
if they're let's say one of those types
who would be on the more atheistic end
because the psychedelics have this
quality of you ingest it sometimes you
encounter some other being but you don't
have to necessarily ascribe that to an
objective reality maybe that's the
union unconscious or just the
unconscious without a union flare
showing up and it's certainly
transformative there's data about that
does one
who believes in the efficacy of
psychedelics have some religiosity to
them just because like i mentioned
there's that criteria of transformative
experience that radically
yeah so um in the history of uh
religious studies we could say
absolutely um could we say that now
uh of like european people european
white people i guess you know americans
canadians who go down to brazil or
central america and do ayahuasca and
then see
beings and things like that and then
come back transformed but maybe don't
believe in the objective reality of
those beings okay so i would say that's
not religious that's you know
that's transformative no doubt um but
within indigenous cultures
especially like with native american the
native american church and they use
peyote in order to get in touch with
what they believe to be presences that
are sacred and then that absolutely
transforms them and informs them as well
and that's a religion okay and you can
also see this within um different even
different forms of catholicism in oaxaca
mexico so if you look at somebody like
maria sabina who you probably don't know
but everybody should know about her
because she's fascinating so she's one
of the most fake she is the most famous
healer in mexico and i believe she died
in the 1980s but um
her whole life she was uh she used
psilocybin to heal people and people
came from all over mexico to be healed
by her and she called the the beings
that she believed she was in contact
through eating psilocybin or drinking
psilocybin tea
um she called these beings little saints
and that's absolutely a religion right
there and in fact believe it or not it's
a it's a denomination it's a form of
catholicism okay and so you can even see
cathedrals down in oaxaca that actually
have mushrooms put into them because
they were built by the indigenous people
and this was part of their religion so
when the spanish came and said you know
build this cathedral for us they had no
clue that they were actually in laying
all these like you know mushrooms in the
architecture and you can actually go
down still and see that so yeah so this
arises i mean it could be a religion
curve do you see what i'm saying it just
depends on whether or not you believe
that it's a
objective reality that's what a religion
has it has this idea that there's
something it's not subjective there's no
subjective transformation there's both
an objective reality that transforms you
subjectively and then you become
transformed but this thing is objective
now i know people who are people here in
north america who do ayahuasca together
have the same visions even though they
don't talk to each other and that
reinforces their belief that there's an
objective reality to this ayahuasca and
they form churches around this okay so
yeah so there's a lot of religion going
on in there whether or not you can
discreetly say this is a discreet
religion and this is why it's just much
more vague than that i know you're
scientist so this is kind of like you
know it it's just not as cut and dry as
we like to say you know oh this is a
religion and this is not a religion and
there are you know it's it's um i think
it has to do with the objective reality
of the you know whether or not these
people believe it's objectively true
and again it could be or it could not be
i don't know we don't actually weigh in
on that but i think it's fascinating
that's part of the reason i find ufos
fascinating is because at this moment in
time what do we have we do have like
people
who are coming out scientists like dr
gary nolan who by the way was in
american cosmic he's james in american
cosmic um my book and i traveled around
with him and he's a sports car
yeah he's got
i think he has a new one now um
but he had one back then too
and um
so well that kind of like threw me off
of what i was going to say sorry i'm so
sorry
you're saying so there's credible
scientists yeah yeah okay so you have
people yeah and you also have you know
these big news outlets that people trust
for good or bad right like new york
times and things like that and they're
basically saying yeah this is real you
know these things exist and they're real
so to me as a person who studies
religion this is the first time in my
life that i've actually seen something
that's religious like this religiosity
that's hooking onto
an objective reality and this is
transforming people
right as we speak
and so i think that you know carl jung
back in the day you know a long time ago
in the 1940s he basically said how lucky
are we that we get to now see we get to
now be at the very beginning of this new
belief system
little did he know how intense it was
gonna get right and so that's uh i think
that we're at a really fascinating point
and as lucky for me i feel like i caught
the wave of it right before it happened
that caught it with american cosmic in
and believe me i took heat for it so you
know i'm here hanging out with gary
nolan from stanford you know we're going
into the new mexico desert with somebody
somebody who is affiliated with our
space program and basically
using these medical med uh metal
detectors looking for this debris from
crash saucers right uh at a site that's
not roswell but is one of the sites
that's you know where a crash is
supposed to have landed in the 1940s now
to me this was all a myth right and i
was going out there to understand how
somebody as amazing as gary and as
amazing as tyler who i call him in my
book he hasn't come out as gary's come
out as himself so i can talk about him
but the other person hasn't i'm like how
do these people who are obviously
rational
how are they believing this that was my
question because this is truly strange
and
i was just i felt like i was a walking
question mark like constantly just what
you know what is are you kidding you
really believe this yes they really
believe this in fact they they put these
you know things into different types of
microscopes and you know they looked at
these in different ways and they're like
yeah this is a these these parts are
anomalous and we believe that they're
they're not earthly and things like that
i mean it was pretty crazy so to me
this is now
uh becoming something that's being
almost like mass-marketed like through
media because you know now we don't have
the same type of media that we had in
the 1950s and 60s where things were slow
things are almost instantaneous now so
when dr gary nolan would say publishes a
paper boom everybody reads it right and
now everybody has this knowledge and so
we're seeing kind of like um
a bunch of changes happening at once and
i find it fascinating for religion for
this kind of
what i call a religiosity it's
definitely not a religion in the
old-time way i believe it's a it's the
formation of a new type of transcendent
religion
a couple of questions so one is you
mentioned that you took some flack i
believe you said you took some heat oh
yes of the release of the book where did
you take the flak from who gave you this
heat
sure okay
so um you have to understand that i am
not the only professor who's delved into
this and gotten heat for it so
and i don't now because obviously
there's a lot out there now the
government has said yeah we have some
cases that we just don't can't explain
and things like that so thankfully my
book got retro
credibility right so it came out before
all of this happened and then it
happened you know just within a couple
years all right so who did i get heat
from so um
i was a chair of my department and i was
a full professor when i was doing this
research and i'd won the research awards
at my university and i was a well-known
professor in catholic history and i
published with
oxford right so
i was already pretty upset that i i
didn't care if people were going to give
me flack because i knew that my
methodology was sound so i was okay with
it but i'd go to a
um
i would go to conferences
and people would
would
call the the work the you know the
research they'd say that's interesting
and if you're in philosophy you know
what that means that means wow
totally weird like not interesting at
all kind of thing
and so um
and i get this a lot but i was still i
still knew that i that it was it's not
that bad
no i know i mean i mean yeah there's no
like you know uh
funding that's taken away a lot of but i
would i didn't tell a lot of people what
i was doing and then the book comes out
and honestly i thought maybe 10 people
would read it like you know it's an
academic book and i thought it was
pretty obscure in terms of like talking
about how technology is shifting the
ways in which people think and i was
taking the ufo as an example of this but
um but it just kind of
went way beyond what i had thought so
that's how i took the heat um i had a
lot of
people
um
i guess
tell me that i'd gone this is such a
terrible term
and i hate this term but this was said
um you've gone native right you know in
in anthropology this means that you now
believe
the people that you're studying you know
are are
what they're saying is true and this is
something you just are you're not
supposed to do
and you know it's a completely horrible
racist term and um that was said of me
things like that so
those that's the kind of heat that i
took
so that's from the academic community or
a subset of the academic community what
about from the public
so for example i imagine that there i
know gary gets this but i know many
people get this plenty where there's
there are the people who consider
themselves to be the rational skeptics
where
are the rational skeptics of the sort
who only follow where the evidence leads
them and this is all woo because there's
such a pausing of evidence and you're
believing people based on testimony and
that's not what one does in
in science and it's not replicable etc
and and and partly that's true but then
the dismissal of it i don't agree with
the deriding and the
and the snide remarks to come along with
that so did you were you on the
receiving end of any
of those
oh definitely i think that a lot of
people will say that
it's
you know
i mean let's take the rational
you know the approach that this is not
rational in my opinion that's completely
rational like if you're seeing things
and you're getting results let's take
this the space program our united states
space program and the russian space
program as an example of this okay and
when i say an example of this what an
example of
um basically people not following the
evidence okay so the evidence is this
that the people who founded our space
programs did a lot of weird science
woo science i would call it woo science
and they still continue to do that tyler
is an example of somebody who's doing
real science you can't replicate what he
did with jack parsons who founded our
space program
verner von braun founded you know he was
german but he came over to our space
program um
and then um constantine jakovsky he
founded the russian space program all
these people created
the calculations that would get us off
of earth right that would get us up into
space okay well that's
big okay
and they did this through means that
looked
irrational they had techniques that they
used and as a person who studies
religion these are identifiable
techniques these are body techniques so
they're using a lot of what we would
call
you know like eschesis that's a greek
word for
um
almost like becoming um very very
disciplined with respect to
your
lifestyle and your mind and your
thoughts so they were going into some
kind of almost like an altered state of
consciousness at least jack parsons was
and then creating these you know kind of
downloading this information um well
what what does that say um i just
recently given a talk and i made this
case i said that's where the data leads
us i mean if we're rational we're going
to say yeah you can't replicate that but
that's where the the data says that
those things actually work like those
kinds of you know um i spoke to carrie
mullis
here i'm gonna
i don't know if you can hear that can
you hear that no no no oh okay never
mind then um
all right carrie mullis he is a nobel
prize winning whizzing chemist right so
he is uh he discovered the polymerase
chain reaction all right now i suggest
to your listeners that they go check out
his web page carrie mullis where he
talks about he died two years ago um but
he basically talks about creativity and
his means of being creative was exactly
like tyler's means of being creative and
very similar to the space program you
know people in the space program and
he's a genius okay and so what i'm
saying is this i'm not a scientist but
i'm saying to scientists
the data looks
weird right it looks weird but i think
it and it looks like you know these
people are doing things that are not
rational but to a person in my field
these things are actually
patterns and why would you ignore those
patterns if they're giving these amazing
results if you're actually you know if
the results
are something that you would you know
you want
why discount than the
body practices that they're engaged in
that's my point and so i think that is
actually rational
there's there's rationality to the woo
let's put it that way
so what if someone says okay the fact
that these practices exist and then
instigate some creative or that spur
some creative insight it doesn't mean
that
what they think is occurring is
necessarily occurring or is objective
and many creative people have practices
that are deviating and peculiar even
newton he engaged in alchemy and let's
imagine that alchemy served as the
inspiration for calculus it doesn't lend
credence to the objective validity of
alchemy it just means that just like wim
hof can say that hey you may have a
creative insight if you run for a while
then jump into a cold bath
maybe that's true and there's an
extremely tight relationship between our
body and our our minds and it doesn't
necessarily mean that
they're
even if it's consistent consistently
when you jump in that bath consistently
when you perform alchemy consistently
when you meditate in this way and and
supposedly talk to beings and so on even
if that's the case it doesn't mean that
the mechanisms that you think are
working are the reasons it just means
the practice work
i totally agree with that yeah i'm i'm
on board with that in fact i would
suggest that that's what we that's the
type you see to to me you're thinking
like a person in religious studies
you're saying there are patterns here
and the patterns have to do with some
body practices right esthesis body
practices but this body but the body
practices are different for each of
those people and they're kind of strange
like if you took jack parsons he did a
lot of really weird things i would not
want to have hung out with him right so
you know he's part of some you know
aleister crowley and people like that i
mean frankly very very different than
constantine tchaikovsky who does very
similar ritualistic things but they have
they are in no way does he view it as a
new form of religion you know he thought
of his as christianity so do you see
what i'm saying and then when tyler's
doing it here in the you know 2000s he's
doing very similar things but he's not
he doesn't think of it as aleister
crowley he would he would be he would
probably be horrified to even think that
it had anything to do with jack parsons
right
so what i'm saying is i agree with you
entirely i think that what we need to do
is we need to identify that these people
do these things and what are these
things and are there patterns yes there
are patterns but what they specifically
believe about them is based on their own
interpretive framework so jack parsons
happened to be in la in the early 20th
century where there was a belief system
in place for him to kind of hook into um
if you look at do you know ramanujan the
mathematician okay he thought that the
goddess lakshmi was whispering those
calculations the math calculations
brilliant math genius into his ears so
that was his interpretive framework you
see what i'm saying um also i when i was
doing american cosmic i was reading up
on creativity and um i forgot the name
of the um the person whose work i had
read but she was really she's really
good um and it's it's there's is cited
there in american cosmic but basically
she said that if you do if you look at
the brains of people who are being
extremely creative we're talking about
creative genius uh what you see is that
something is shut down i think she said
in the executive lobe or something like
that the executive promotion is shut
down and the people that are being
creative are attributing their
creativity to something objective
yeah so they're attributing it to
something objective that doesn't mean
that there's something objective there
it just means that that's what they're
doing
right and so i that's the way i would
like to do this research and that's how
we can avoid you know a lot of people
are are just they have knee-jerk
reactions to it for some reason like
that's woo you know well it's weird that
works and i want to know why it works
that's basically my position
now i'm super interested in what
constitutes a religion and what doesn't
which is why i have many questions about
this sure the people who
label what you just outlined as wu
the stigmatization
is there something that is common among
those people that
makes the stigmatization itself a form
of religion so that is to say when the
people who are of the more atheistic
type not picking on them it's just the
easiest that come to mind when the
atheistic types make fun of religion and
they say that i'm not religious is there
something religious about that
oh i hear what you're saying um
no i don't necessarily think so i know
that a lot of people say that atheism is
like a religion because you know people
are
you know either you are you aren't
atheist and you know you're in our
community and it's kind of exclusionary
right and some religions are like that
not all but some are and
um they're dogmatic like they're
dogmatic atheists i think that's what
they're trying to say is there's a
dogmatism about
some atheists who like i said like to
put like to make a strong man argument
about religion and then like knock it
down and say see there's nothing there
right um
yeah i don't think so i think that um
there's a variety of atheist beliefs
anyway right so when i say i was atheist
with respect to ufos
i didn't believe in the objective
reality of it of ufos okay um and i
thought that people who did i thought
they were completely wrong
and i'm not that way anymore so you can
be atheist about some things and not
atheist about other things with respect
to god okay um some religions are are
atheists
there are some atheistic religions
so religion has the reputation of
being shut up and listen to what i say
and don't think for yourself and don't
question how much of that is true i know
that's a straw man but how much of it is
how is it true how is it not true
yeah that's great so within um different
denominations of religions also let's
take i'm most familiar with catholicism
and christianity and i would say that
within christianity
um a lot
of
believers within certain forms of
christianity denominations that are
relatively new would be like that
you know i'm here in the south but i
grew up in california and i was raised
you know pretty eclectic in california
but i'm mostly catholic right and so
when i came here
and i taught the students a lot of the
students in the south in the united
states didn't even believe or know that
catholicism was christianity they would
say
dr basulka what religion are you and a
lot of times i wouldn't tell them and i
say oh you have to i'll tell you at the
end of the semester but i would say okay
i'm catholic and they'd say oh you
should become a christian
right so they just didn't have an idea
they just didn't know their history you
know catholicism actually predates their
religion which is baptist or something
like that
so i would say that probably the more
recent
christian denominations are like that
and obviously there are some muslim
denominations that are like that as well
or they're not at least they're not like
you need to belong to us but basically
you know we have the true
idea of what a religion is but not all
okay so a very small minority in those
in each of those religions
you won't find it at all at least
uh
historically in hinduism and hinduism
you know it's very regional and a lot of
people who are hindu would never say you
sh there's you can even convert
because there are some religions that
you just can't ever convert to because
you actually have to be born into the
culture right why would you want to do
that or all roads lead to brahma right
so they're all you know so if you're
catholic be a really good catholic and
you can you can reach moksha
that's the idea okay so so a lot of
people in
north america
canada united states they don't
understand the variety of religious
belief
and that's what i'd like to convey to
people you know they if people knew that
more and even religious people they
don't even know that like a lot of
religious people they you know it
depends on which type of religion
they're from but
you know they
they have these own perceptions of what
religion is as well
i was speaking to coleman hughes and he
was telling me that kurt look these
conversations that you and i are having
right now these are not the kind of
conversations that you can have in a
church
the church would just say this is what
you should believe and and they're
dogmatic and so on and i told them that
you'd be extremely surprised and then he
said well most
of it is the case or most religions are
like that i don't know if that's that's
actually true but even if that's true
then my question to him was what because
i imagine it's 70 true maybe 30 percent
are extremely open-minded and allow
inquiry like this even questioning of
god and so on the history of philosophy
is filled with people who consider
themselves christians who are even
questioning in their work does god exist
so it's not actually true that you can't
question
the foundational aspects of your
religion and still be a member of that
religion then the broader question to me
comes well at what percentage at what
point do you say
religion says so and so because a large
enough percentage of people who are
religious believe so and so well it's
more of a category question so if ten
percent of people have deviating points
of view then do you okay we'll forget
about that i don't know how to
do you excommunicate them is that what
you're asking
so it's more like at what point do you
generalize enough to say religion says
so and so because 70 of people who
consider themselves to be religious say
it you probably wouldn't say religion
says so and so 50 of people believed i
wouldn't even say religion says so you
can't even say that because which you
have to specifically say that's like
saying
humans say so right because well which
humans americans canadians you know um
people from europe or you know
uh saudi arabia
so you have to identify which religion
because if you went to buddhist
countries even like say japanese
buddhism and you said you know they're
not going to be telling you about
believing in a god they will be telling
you to question everything to the point
you know what i'm saying so those kind
you know so there are so many
forms of religion that i think that you
can't say religion says this
you can basically say religion at this
point in time in 1980
in north carolina
you know in wilmington
baptists will say that if you don't
believe this you're going to go to hell
or something like that that's prob you
know you can you have to be really
specific instead of general and you have
to take it by a case-by-case basis but
in my opinion i would say that
people who are religious
um
mostly
are not going they're going to
allow for
i would say even 70
they're going to allow for you to
question
everything because that's how because in
a lot of religions if you go to the
mystical traditions almost in almost in
every religion there's a mystical
tradition if even in philosophy there's
a mystical tradition and that mystical
tradition is generally questioning
everything okay that's how one comes
upon this mysticism like whoa
like what you know this question
and i think that um
that that's the goal
because once one does that that's when
one is open to these kinds of highly
creative events
earlier we mentioned dogma dogmatic has
a reputation in our educated culture as
being a net negative has little
redeeming qualities other than maybe to
regulate the populace and that's
actually a negative anyway so can you
steal man dogma can you make the case
for dogma
do i advocate for dogma is that what
you're saying can i add no no i don't
think the more rational types would say
that so-and-so is dogmatic that means
it's a disgraceful quality and i don't
think that dogma itself is a negative i
think it can be out of balance yeah how
does okay so what is a dogma so a dogma
is a belief that becomes central to
an institution okay so in the united
states we have this constitution
and you know all humans are created
equal
um that that may or may not be true but
that's absolutely a dogma
it's it's a
you know it's it's ingrained in
americans so if you're born here you
grew up listening to that and you
believe that all human beings are
created equal okay and then when human
beings are not created or not treated
equally you hold that up and you say
wait a minute this is what we believe
and therefore we must act this way and
if if we're not acting that way then
there's a problem okay so that would be
a dogma and a dogma isn't necessarily
true or false it's just basically
something that all these people hold to
be
true and then we must it's like a belief
right we talked about the definition of
belief earlier and then we and we
we call it like a self-evident truth
that's like a dogma right self-evident
right
um but it doesn't necessarily mean that
it's actually true now to become
dogmatic means that
say let's take the catholic church as an
example since i i've studied that um
within the catholic church purgatory is
a dogma right the belief in purgatory
you must believe you must believe in
this place called purgatory else you're
not a catholic or else you go to hell or
what is it what is the house there yeah
so basically you're not a um you're not
a catholic following
catholic uh doctrine
okay okay so you could you could
feasibly
be excommunicated or something like that
i doubt that would ever happen because
now people don't even know what
purgatory is catholics or anyone right
so but it's still there it's still a
dogma so that's what my question was
back in the day was like wait a minute
people used to do this all the time
right and even you know our grandparents
are like pray for the souls in purgatory
like we don't even know what that means
what does it even mean okay so um
so that dog must seem to have
disappeared
but it hasn't actually the church is a
lot it will probably never get rid of it
so it's still a dogma but it's just not
one that's practiced
does that shed light a little bit on
dogma yeah and what's the method that
dogma changes like what's the updating
mechanism for dogma because it sounds to
me the word dogma would imply that it's
set in stone this is the way it is so
how can you ever change it yeah i know
that's really a good question and i
think that this is how it works frankly
this is what i showed in my book about
purgatory is i showed that
when did purgatory become a dogma well
it wasn't there from the very beginning
believe it or not okay so i think the
catholic church this is how it views
purgatory is that purgatory is an actual
state that souls do go to okay and it's
objective of humans
therefore
purgatory was like discovered or found
in the 1200s right
all right so that's kind of the the idea
or let's put it like this is kind of the
um the unwritten history of purgatory
this is just how people think about it
that's really not what happened kurt if
you go back you'll find that people
actually went to specific places where
they would go into caves underground if
they were particularly bad people okay
say like they've killed people their
bishop would send them to a place in
ireland and there was also a place in
italy
um where there was a cave and it's still
there by the way in uh ireland it's
called lochderg and it's a place called
um it's on a lake and it's an island on
a lake it's called st patrick's
purgatory and this was in the tents tens
and eleven hundreds and bad people would
have to go spend the night in that cave
and if they survived that cave they
would have been purged of their sins
and so purgatory actually came from
these weird these i wish i shouldn't say
weird because we still do things like
this you know like i'll be good you know
i won't eat any bad food for 10 days and
then hopefully this good result will
happen kind of thing right so we kind of
do those kinds of things all right so
that's so purgatory actually came from
some
basic practices that people did like
physical practices
so it's actually a physical place
quick question about that what was it
about the cave that was so dangerous
that made it unlikely or difficult for
one to survive the night there
i think part of it was just the
claustrophobia of going into this cave
for 24 hours you couldn't eat you
couldn't drink it's probably pretty
scary
um but also people believed in spirits
and demons right and that perhaps they
would meet spirits and demons in that
cave and there was a very famous um book
called saint patrick's purgatory written
by a chris
basically about a crusader knight who
went into the cave and fought demons and
things like that it was actually a
medieval bestseller
and a lot of people read it in fact
dante read it and based purgatorio on
this right
so this was pre-dante and this is where
the dogma of purgatory derived now how
did it leave
well it a dogma goes away through time
when people just
stop knowing where it came from in the
first place and what it's about i think
it's just a natural thing things aren't
written in stone they come and go so a
lot of people say well the doctrines and
truths of the church never change well
they look like they change at least how
we believe in them changes
so yeah when i was researching you i was
so pleased to see you mentioned
heidegger because not many people do
especially not in the ufo scene
what the heck does heidegger have to do
with ufos
yeah that's for sure
and you mentioned that there's something
about technology
and the
and not viewing them instrumentally
that heidegger had and i would like you
to expand on that please yeah sure so um
i like heidegger and a lot of colleagues
of mine hate heidegger and heidegger's
kind of you know demonized in philosophy
because this is what happened to him
he's really interesting so he was you
know he hung out with dickenstein and
people like that in philosophy and he
was a
straight up like rationalist philosopher
okay
and then strangely enough he actually
hung out with zen buddhists
so there's a school in japan called the
kyoto school of zen buddhism and the
people that were part of that school
were also philosophers so they and
heidegger would have conversations and
heidegger actually had a mystical
experience and after that he started to
do exactly what socrates used to do and
that's why he though if you look at his
work you'll see that it was like
straight up kind of boring philosophy
until all of a sudden he started to name
everything that he wrote it was a
question
what is technology
what is an object
okay and so he went at it in a socratic
fashion of basically you know what
socratic dialogue is right so the
process of okay so um
it's a process
but the process is basically to ask
and we're not gonna find out we're going
to find out more about it but there's
going to be a point we're going to say i
don't know what the heck that is right i
don't know what it is
and that's what socrates would say and
that's why socrates was supposed to be
the man who was the most intelligent man
in the world because he said he didn't
know and he was honest
and also really smart i don't know
so i think dogma is knowing
and that's why it has a bad name because
i think at heart we all know because
this is the question that that heidegger
wanted to revisit why is there something
rather than nothing
like why are we here
rather than why are we self-conscious so
he's basically coming at this question
and questing everything right
questioning what is art
well you know i mean he was one of the
first philosophers to really get into
this question of technology and he
actually in my opinion he was visionary
because he basically saw technology as
basically becoming our infrastructure
and also
more than that right so he when i don't
know if you've ever read the essay what
is technology but he goes back and he he
talks about it with respect to
the um
the greek temple
so for the greek temple you know for the
greeks the temple housed
their gods and goddesses it how's the
sacred right okay and then he goes
through the medieval time period
heidegger and he says for the catholics
it was the cathedral that housed god
he said with technology what's going to
house technology he was looking at
technology as a new form of the sacred
and that's what i found fascinating
that's what led me to jacques valet
actually
meaning that it's an interface but what
do you mean when you say that the
technology houses the sacred
okay yeah that is going to determine how
we live in the world and how we um
like our relationship with the world
life is going to be so as a catholic
media medieval catholic your
relationship was with the world was
basically you the belief structure of
the catholic church which you know you
encountered god in the cathedral
and then supposedly from that experience
your experience like you know going to
the purgatory cave or something like
that you it determined the way in which
you lived in the world so heidegger was
basically saying what that was for the
greeks being a temple
and it was for the cathedral was for the
catholics technology is going to be for
the people of the future and he was
basically saying you know his grandkids
or something like that it's coming is
what he was saying but you know he also
envisioned something really bad on the
horizon
and um i'm not quite sure what it was
that he envisioned but it wasn't good
because i end my book with a quote from
heidegger and he didn't actually want
that quote he didn't want that quote
known
until he died and then when he died he
that quote could be published and the
the quote is
um only a god can save us now
and when he said god he wasn't meaning
the kind of straw man god of dawkins
religion no he was meaning something
entirely like a mutation or something
that was you know something that was so
far out of our own experience of humans
that that you know it would be
it would save us basically it's like if
this was a story it would be a like a
deus ex machina
yeah yeah yeah that would be it yeah
okay you mentioned this was related to
jacques valley yeah okay so um all right
so heidegger has always been some uh you
know his his uh work was fascinating to
me just as hannah and rent's work she
and he were
she learned from him
he was her professor
and so um
these kind of these
these uh philosophers formed a lot of
how i looked at things because i grew up
in california
near
well in the dot com
you know this was like my
meal you i guess you could say my social
media was on the 90s with you know the
dot com stuff and everything like that
and i lived there that's where i lived
is in northern california so i got to
see kind of technology take off right
um
and
i also so so heidegger was always on the
back burner
right
um
and then i met and then when i was done
with my book oh by the way i think he
had a catholic burial so he wasn't
actually a practicing catholic but he
made sure that he had a catholic burial
which i always found fascinating so okay
so what happens then after
okay so jacques okay i attend this first
i i knew about jacques work because he
wrote um a book um passport to magonia
yeah for some reason i thought john mack
wrote that oh no john mack wrote
passport to the cosmos a reference
to
uh
jacques passport to magonia so i read
passport to magonia and it to me it felt
like i was reading my book on purgatory
and so i reached out to him through um
hard mail right like snail mail i wrote
him a letter and i sent it to him and i
said i wonder if you'd talk to me
because i'm in california a lot and he
said yes so um
so we started a correspondence he was
fascinated with my research because he
wanted to see
the primary sources for a lot of the
catholic you know because he's from a
catholic country and has that you know
um was able to read latin and that kind
of thing so um i shared a lot of my
my work with him
and
i went to a conference where i was it
was a small conference in california and
jacques was there
and it occurred to me what i thought was
really odd was that jacques wasn't only
a person who was interested in ufos
but he was also a person who was pretty
instrumental in the creation of
technology in our country
and he you know he had a phd in
information science from northwestern in
the 1960s i mean you know so he's at the
very beginning of two
absolutely
on what i think are inexplicably related
things ufos and technology like this
belief it's almost as if the belief in
ufos is almost the religious support
of the infrastructure of technology
that's how i saw it so to me to me
jacques was like a walking
heideggerian essay
to me that's what he seemed to me to be
and so i couldn't stop like thinking
that and so i read everything and this
is before he put all of his stuff on
academia edu so before that i went to
you know i searched everything out on
microfiche you know in the library and i
read all of his 1970s stuff and
everything and i was like wow i'm right
about him he is like this hiding gary
but he i don't even think he knows who
martin tyler he's never read him i'm
sure you know and so um
yeah so that's how then i i
understood his work
and
and to me you couldn't take the
technological
work that he did away from the ufo
studies that he did to me they went hand
in hand
okay so what i was going to ask
is is there
a higher percentage of people who are
catholic who study the phenomenon more
than the general population let's say
have you found that
okay so i found that because i was at
the vatican and i spent time at the
observatory there in castle gandalfo
and um
i know brother guy console mono who is
the observatory he's the jesuit monk
who's the head of the observatory he's
an astronomer
and they have a meteorite collection
there and stuff it's pretty cool so i
got to stay there and i've known him now
for i don't know a lot of a lot of years
i guess
um
and i also talked to lots of people at
the vatican
like peter gompel he's a uh
he's he's in his 90s and he is um
he was like a people advisor
and so this is what i can say about
catholicism and
the subject of ufos is that
the people that i've talked to are very
open-minded about it
and just as curious as as you and i are
and some believe and some don't believe
so there's no right at this point
there's no definite kind of dogma or
doctrine
um
about
ufos for the vatican right so um okay so
that said
there when i did get into this this um
research some very odd things happen to
me that
never would have happened to me had i
stayed in
the study of normal catholic history and
stuff like that like so i um i was uh
you know people in my book a lot of them
i i became involved with the invisible
college do you know the people that okay
so i became involved with the invisible
college and
after about a year and a half
i recognized that every single one of
them
either was a practicing catholic or had
been
you know had come from a catholic
background and the ones that were the
most intense into the research were
actually practicing catholics
and um
i don't understand that actually so i'm
not quite sure why that is the case
but that's the case
do you have any speculation as to why
that may be the case
like ideas you're toying with i mean it
makes it's gonna make it's gonna sound
very crazy and i'm just if i tell you
okay i will tell you what my my
speculation is but there's no proof for
it
um it's just what i think so it has
nothing to do with me being a professor
and kind of you know weighing down okay
so basically i think that um well every
single one of them has a clearance
um
most of them were involved in some way
with the
information about ufos and the public
and we know about project blue book
and we know that in with project blue
book there was a disinformation campaign
right and we know some of the people
that were supposed to do that
um it could be that people feel guilty
i'm not sure
and so they go back to the religion of
their youth in order to you know because
it's pretty intense studying ufos
and then maybe just you know make maybe
engaged in disinformation and things
like that i mean this is pretty heavy
and um
i didn't mean to find stuff out like
that you know about
the ufo phenomena i just kind of
happened upon it and
that the work that i do is historical
work mainly so i've done a lot of
history in the campaigns and the stuff
like that so
yeah so perhaps
that's the reason i'm not quite sure
does the vatican acknowledge or see any
similarities between angelic encounters
and alien encounters
yes some people do yeah some people do
definitely i mean one of the uh former
directors of the observatory
uh definitely believed in um et's and
believed that et's
were
another kind of subset of god's creation
okay so that's another thing is that
a lot of people think like atheists or
people that i talk to like you know
people in congress or something like
that they're like if we if people
find out that ufos are real or something
it's gonna really you know
you know the religions are gonna crash
they're gonna implode and people are
gonna not believe in their religions
well that's not true at all because
people already who are religious have
categories for anomalous phenomena and
anomalous beings and non-human
intelligence so they already have these
categories in place that say atheists
don't have or some atheists just don't
have and so i think that that people who
are religious are going to be actually
very
in fact i think they already are they're
completely
okay with the idea that there are
perhaps ets
um or non-human entities not human
intelligent entities
because they already believe it
you know
in terms of the vatican or in terms of
some of the other religious people that
that you've encountered who sorry that
you have yes encountered that have that
are devoted do they see aliens to be a
modern interpretation of the
of some ancient of what we placed into
religious stories or do they see that
aliens are now the interpretation of
what was there before
so uh
hopefully you understand what i'm saying
are the aliens primary and the angel
secondary like the false interpretation
or is it the angels are being
interpreted from our materialistic
culture as aliens yeah or demons yeah
yeah i think that's a good way to put it
um
and i have a friend uh jeff kreipel he's
at rice university and he talks about
this actually i forgot he has a word for
it but i forgot what it was um but
basically he says that you know we tend
to think that
the people of the past mis interpreted
these kinds of things and they called
them angels and demons when actually
they're ufos right they're unidentified
you know advanced aircraft kind of
things and that we have a much more
accurate interpretation he says that's
baloney you know
you know because they're both
interpretations and they're both based
on what we know right now
you know and so
who's to say you know people 100 years
from now are going to look back on us
and say
look what they believed that was really
funny you know and so that's what i
think we have to do is we have to get
back to the heideggerian impulse of
basically the socrates impulse of
basically saying
what like what's going on you know and
maybe
try to not conclude
and just kind of observe and i think
that we'll get information if we do that
that's what i think we should do
instead of calling it something why
don't we just observe it and note
patterns
because there are patterns okay so
fatima right so you know about the 1917
miracle the sun
fatima oh oh that
yeah this is a vatican kind of virgin
mary apparition thing okay oh no then i
don't know it it's not the sun that
moved in the sky this is different no it
is it's the it's called the miracle of
the sun but it was it was supposed to be
um from the virgin mary it was based on
an apparition of the virgin mary so um
if you look at some of those documents
uh
and again
the primary sources were it wasn't is
don't attribute it to me or jacques
ballet or even jeff kreipel because
there were two
people who did this research this um and
i
i can send you the info
curt please let me because these people
deserve the credit you know uh okay i
will make a note so send info of
yeah they did some great research on the
primary sources and what they found were
that there were a lot of things that
looked very
you know what we would call ufos because
there was a man who had been um with i
think there was 70 000 people there um
in fatima and he was a doctor and an
atheist and he looked up and what he saw
was something that looked like a
pearlized disc that was spinning around
and around and around you know so you
know if we could just get these kinds of
descriptions
and put them all together i think that
we would get and without any kind of
dogma associated with it like you know
oh it has to be this or it has to be
that because there will be a lot of that
people will be upset um and i don't know
why people are so upset about this um
when i first did my research by the way
i would get a lot of emails from people
in fact i had to report it to my
university in 2018 i was just getting
hammered by pretty weird emails
and so you know i just couldn't do my
work so i had
you know i i had to report it to we have
we have police at the university we have
tech experts like i t people and so i
reported that and i remember
this is in 2018 chris padgett was our
chief of police on the university campus
at the time and he looked at the emails
and he said this looks like religious
extremism
and i said yeah that's what it looks
like religious extremism so someone who
does who's has nothing to do with what i
studied even identified it as looking
like that so if you just say if you say
what i just said why don't we just
observe the patterns there will be a lot
of pushback to that for some reason
people would just be really upset about
it that i don't have either a catholic
framework or a religious framework or if
i don't have the you know what's going
right now is the us government's these
are advanced technology framework like
you have to have that framework now or
else you're going to have pushback why
can't we just look at it and just
identify what we know about it using
science and
religious studies and sociology and all
the things that we have all the tools
that we have that's my suggestion just
look it look at it
have you found any connection between
near-death experiences and the
phenomenon
or any other part of your studies and
near-death experiences i at some point
in the summer plan on taking a deep dive
into them but was starting with dean
raiden if you've heard of him but i
haven't done so yet so i'm curious yes i
know dean um
so yes i have actually um what's really
interesting right now is that i'm um
doing some research into japanese ufos
and um what i think is really
interesting is that they're different
i would call them like different ufos
there's our you know the us military's
ufo right which is you know these things
that like lou elizondo talks about that
kind of thing well that looks a little
bit different than the ufos that the
japanese talk about okay
and then you know so so near-death
experiences what i found is this is that
strangely
people who've had near-death experiences
seem to have a lot of these post-ufo
effects
that people who see ufos have
which is i don't know if you and again i
hate to do this but i'm going to uh the
movie arrival i don't like to cite a
movie as as a as a framework for like
you know talking about something but in
this movie arrival um one of the gifts
that the aliens give to humans is the
the knowledge of time like you know that
time is actually you know they had four
knowledge and you know time is not
linear so you can know things and so a
lot of people who have near death
experiences and you have had experiences
of a ufo
all of a sudden seem to know things that
are going to happen um some not all of
them but a lot of them
and uh so this is something that i found
i also found that a lot of people who've
had ufo experiences
seem to associate those ufo experiences
with um where people died so i know an
experiencer he's a very well-known
experiencer and he said that he saw a
ufo where his wife had died of a car
accident years earlier
now in japan
these orbs that you know here in the
united states we call them ufos but they
see them in japan
they're they're identified as souls like
souls that of debt deceased people like
during the tsunami of 2011 there were so
many of these and people saw them and
they said these are the souls right of
the people who died during the tsunami
and so i i think that's really
interesting so yeah there's some
correlations there
in japan were they referring to the orbs
or were they referring to the craft when
they said the souls
the orbs
okay you mentioned one time that
vale told you about how these alphabet
agencies work and that you were able to
see how they work up close and personal
i think in terms of the strategies that
they use though i wasn't sure exactly
what you meant by the strategies like
you mean the disinformation strategies
like what are you for the collection of
of data strategies the silencing of
people i wasn't sure what you meant so
do you mind expounding on that yeah some
of the strategies that they use would be
there were two specific ways in which
they spread disinformation at least when
project blue book was going on and i
believe they probably still do this and
i think probably yeah this is this is
what i've experienced up close um
they cultivate two types of people as
assets and when i say assets those
people sometimes don't even know that
they're being cultivated in fact they
don't know um and that's why they're
assets is because they're an asset to be
they're you being used right uh to
propagate misinformation one of those
persons is like the benefits you know
have you heard of uh paul benefits
who i've heard
yeah so this was a a person who was not
mentally
stable
and but was near an air force base and
believed in ufos and um
rick dodi richard doty who worked for
the air force as a special agent
he
um he targeted
benefits
and put stuff on his computer to make
him think that
a ufo invasion was imminent okay
and then of course benefits then looks
crazy right or crazier so you know
vulnerable people like that they're
targeted and they're used to kind of
create a stigma associated with ufos if
crazy people believe in ufos i don't
want to believe in them you see what i'm
saying so that happened and then also um
linda molten howe they went for people
like her who
was a legitimate journalist right she
has some credentials from stanford and
they target her and they give her
misinformation and they bring her on
base or something like that and they say
look this is going to come out so those
are two ways that you get cultivated as
an asset
um you're not an asset to yourself or
your life or your family but you're
their asset now where they're you know
cultivating you so um there was a point
in my research where i basically severed
all ties with anybody in the invisible
college except for
jacques who i do trust and gary okay and
gary by the way is not technically in
the invisible college um
he's an invisible one
he's a visible one right but um but yeah
so i just didn't want that in my life at
all because you know i wanted to do
straight up research i didn't want to to
you know because my research could
easily be used to
further some agenda because i'm doing
historical research that's showing that
these things are that these very strange
aerial phenomena have been around if i
didn't do that research i didn't know
this i would assume that there's some
kind of a program like a weapons program
going on that's what i would think was
was happening at this point now there
might be a weapons program going on in
which case my research would be valuable
to them
so how do i do my research and and you
know stop from being cultivated so i
guess at some point i recognize that
that that's a real thing
and um
i mean it kind of recognized it already
because i wasn't sure what was going on
in american cosmic at the beginning but
i'm a researcher who's honest and i said
that in almost every chapter with tyler
i basically said you know james and i
and james is gary i'd say we weren't
quite sure if we were being set up for
misinformation or not but subsequently
james actually went you know gary went
along and you know checked out the the
debris and found that it was very
strange and so
you know something's happening
yeah he comes up a lot um
i'm not super familiar with a lot of his
work but i have colleagues who are in
the space program who um who read his
work and like it and um yeah so but i'm
i'm not a person who
knows it enough to authoritatively say
something about it
same i'm going to be speaking with him
soon but i haven't had a chance to look
into his research on the interview that
you did with the that ufo podcast you
mentioned that you uncovered something
that you weren't supposed to and you
don't have to mention exactly what that
is
but frankly i'm concerned about that as
well it's one of the reasons i don't
like to take a look at data that's
classified or that i can't share even if
i'm extremely interested i tend to not
look at that in my inbox or take people
up on their offers if they offer it to
me i don't want to be in a place where i
have knowledge that i have to either lie
about or obfuscate or hide and etc
i want to ask what was it that you
uncovered but perhaps you can speak
around it
okay i'm trying to think um if this was
something
i have the exact
timeline the exact statement
yeah so let's see if i can bring it up
here
28. i'll just send you the link so that
you can listen to it because i can't
play it for you well there's a lot i
felt a lot more danger frankly when i
was when the government hadn't
admitted that this was happening okay
because
it was i think it there was there was
danger you know there was danger um
and
what if i uncovered something that
people didn't want uncovered which
apparently i think i did
um
so he said apparently you think you did
but you're not sure but anyway so if if
you could recall what you're referring
to
yeah okay so um
i mean i think there were a lot of
things that happened that
maybe weren't supposed to happen but did
and it was only because
you know i was
looking into it and had the tools to
help me figure it out so
um
i think i mean i think the fact that
i tried to
i mean
look it's dirty laundry for the air
force right
looking into these programs and
basically you know american cosmic came
out
and
all of a sudden people are admitting
that these things have happened
and that there were programs of study
and so
um
and i'm not you know i'm actually
legitimate researcher so i'm not
actually out to
make a bunch of money doing this or make
you know a movie about ufos or anything
like that um i just happen to find this
stuff out
and you know that's kind of weird that's
a weird position for me to be in so i
think that that's what was going on and
um
i'm not so i think that's what i was
referring to i mean
you know they were doing stuff and no
one knew about it and well some people
knew about it but the american people
didn't know about it and now they do
because the new york times
from the people that you've spoken to or
there's what you've heard through the
grapevine
is it the case that roswell is
not the recovery of balloon debris that
it indeed is some ufo craft that is
either deliberately landed or
or accidentally landed
okay so that's the that's the question
right so that's um that's the mythology
of prometheus this uh this idea that
somehow we were you know some people
call that site the donation site right
or the gifting site and that's very
promethean that's right along the lines
of this myth and so that's how i felt
very uncomfortable as a person who's
rational
going into basically what looked to be a
living mythology okay a mythology that
was actually people actually were living
and believing it okay
so i'm not going to take the bait and
say that
that's the fact
i don't know if it's the fact
and i know that a lot you know it used
to be that thinking that or just saying
that would would cause one to be called
a quack or something like that right or
you know conspiracy theorists or
something like that believe it or not
the culture has changed so much that now
if you don't believe that people think
you're
bad or wrong or something it seems so no
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna believe or
disbelieve i don't know but i was at one
of those places
what are your thoughts on ce5 so it's a
method of oh i know what it is
okay yeah yeah
um okay so i do know that people i know
people who do it and i know that um
people say oh i've had success with it
but i mean i wouldn't be doing it
i don't know exactly i feel the same you
know
i feel like it's playing with it's such
a
it's such an unknown with such a drastic
consequence that it's it's worse than
playing with fire
yeah i'm not gonna do it
i'm not gonna do it
well forget about whether or not you're
gonna do it what have you heard about it
is there efficacy to it what occurs
during it
yeah so i i have heard a lot of people
say that they have you know initiated
contact through the methods of ce5
um
i've had people ask me to do it with
them right and be in communities of
people who do it i stay away from that
no i'm not gonna do that now why do i
say that because
uh well for one thing
a lot you know
learning about religious traditions you
do learn there's a lot of things that
actually happen and you don't know why
okay and so i already believe that
certain things can happen
i don't really need to have up close
knowledge of this and nor do i think
that we can predict the consequences
so i guess that's my point is that yeah
i do believe that these kinds of things
work but just like we had you know just
like we talked about with the woo
science you know
that
just because people are doing it and
getting these effects
doesn't mean that the story they're
telling themselves and each other about
it is true
so i guess that's how i feel about it is
we're not certain about it why do it
and plus i've had also another thing is
that i've had so many people ask me to
do it and they were almost like
they wanted me to do it so badly that i
thought i don't really want to do this
because they're asking me you know they
really so much want me to do it i surely
don't want to do it now why is that the
case because you feel like it's peer
pressure and there's something wrong
about it like drugs or
why is it the case that if they're
putting so much pressure on you you
don't want to do it
yeah because i feel like you know if
somebody's so invested in me doing it
that
either they're getting something from it
or
they're you know i really don't know i'm
suspicious it just sets off alarms and
i'm not quite sure what those alarms are
but no way i wouldn't do it anyway but
especially when people really want you
to do it
you mentioned that in some of the
circles that you've been in that the
case of bob lazar it isn't as dismissed
as it is in the popular culture and what
he says comports with
yeah other reports in such a way that it
makes much of his account true or likely
to be true even if certain specifics of
the account isn't yeah can you expound
on that sure so a lot of the people that
i talked to in the you know like who are
like tyler basically um believed lazar
okay which i thought was fascinating
because like he's so
dismissed okay for the most part
but they didn't dismiss him at all and
so i thought that's fascinating um what
did he see did he see actually
extraterrestrials or did he see weapons
or you know what did he see he saw
something that caused
a
you know a huge reaction and pushback
and discrediting of him and that kind of
thing you know to the point where he
said i wish i had never said anything in
the first place right and basically
that's what some of the people told me
just before my book came out they said
there might be a point where you wish
that you didn't do this and so i'm not
like bob lazar in that i'm not saying
this was extraterrestrial right i'm not
saying that i'm saying there's a
development at play and let's pay
attention to it because it first it has
to do with religion
and belief systems but there's something
really strange about it going on and i
think we have to give it you know we
look at it but i'm not suggesting that
any kind of
hypothesis about it is true like he did
like we this is extraterrestrial how did
you know
i don't think he said that he actually
was he's extremely careful with his
words he would say i don't know all i
know is that i worked on a craft and
that there were documents given to me
that said they were extraterrestrial but
that could be misinformation
what i do know it operates in this
manner or it seems to operate in this
manner but he was extremely careful yeah
as far as
yeah no he should be definitely that
would be the correct way to go about
doing that kind of thing to be involved
in that is to not conclude and also to
basically because there's been precedent
for mis disinformation you have to
assume that some of it's going to be at
play
especially now
and in fact we have better tools for
disinformation today than we ever did
better tools for
recognizing disinformation or for the
dissemination of it both
how do you defend yourself against
disinformation
what are some of the tools what are some
of the people who are watching right
sure okay so in american cosmic i went
through hoaxes of ufos right and i said
that hoaxes of ufos have um
they we should credit them for the
spread of belief about ufos because a
lot of people look at hoax ufos you know
if i let's put it this way i've received
so many videos of
unidentified flying objects okay and
some of them look pretty legit because
now i have a lot of friends who i can
say what is this you know and they'll
say okay it's not a drone it's not a
plane it's not okay it's unidentified
and then i have hoaxed ones where you
know you can generally see the outlines
and it looks you know okay so i showed
that to
a person who's very well known in the
ufo community household name
um who's written a book bestseller new
york times bestseller and i showed this
person both videos or i showed the
person one video and i said look check
this out and the person that did not to
that person looked like a ufo
because that they had been so
enculturated as to what a ufo is
supposed to look like even though it
most likely doesn't look like that right
so there so but that was really a ufo in
the sense that it was fully an
unidentified flying object whereas the
other one was completely hoaxed and they
thought that that one was legitimate
video so i don't think we have the tools
to be able to adjudicate what's
ufo and what's not so i think that when
we see things especially and their video
you know and that kind of thing um like
jacques vale i had always said believe
nothing you know and use your
discernment okay so i think that um
in today's world of you know uh deep
fakes and things like that it's pretty
impossible i think to to figure that
stuff out so i think that the best
uh default action is just to not believe
and if it seems crazy the most likely is
not real
something else i'd like you to
elaborate on if you don't mind is the
contrast between the academic world and
then the government world with respect
to how they operate openness versus
closeness because generally the more
skeptically minded people take the
academic view and they can't imagine
that the reason for closedness would be
anything other than falseness or
beguiling or whitewashing
i have to admit that i myself am similar
to this in the sense that while i'm not
an academic it's the place where i'm
most comfortable in it's was my training
in a sense so i have a difficult time
with concealment and non-disclosure so
why don't you justify or make the case
for closedness
okay sure so all right and this can be
applied by by the way to the vatican as
well not just to ufo great great
insiders
okay so all right
a lot of
i'll give an example from my actual life
so something that was tangential to
my ufo research but it happened during
it was my catholic research into the
saints of the catholic church that um
bilocated and levitated and i was going
i was um
i had funding from
a billionaire who was interested in this
research this catholic research he's
catholic and so um
i went with tyler actually brought tyler
with me to the vatican and we checked it
out and i you know looked at the the
records and saw just you know
so much information about
saint joseph of copertino who was known
you know he was said to have levitated
and things like that some other things
anyway so um the billionaire fusion
american
with with some of the people who helped
me
um establish the funding to get there to
the vatican to do this research
they wanted to purchase the manuscript
which was a vatican document okay they
wanted to
own it okay
and so
they said diana can you convince the
vatican to give this document to us now
this is a document from the 1700s that
is a sacred document to a country
that's not a democracy
right this is a pre-modern
country
and so the people in the united states
who were they were comprised of
academics and then a billionaire right
and so they basically said
surely they would do that they would
give it to us so that we could study it
and i said i don't think they're going
to do that i think that you have to be a
little bit uh you know we have to be
nuanced in asking for this because
this is their sacred tradition you know
and we just can't do that we just can't
give it to them it's like if you ask the
united states to give up the liberty
bell
or you know over the actual constitution
right i mean we're talking about
something so and they were asking not
simply to give it up but to buy it like
offer the money for it
yeah you know like we want to buy this
and they didn't want a picture of it
that didn't suffice for some reason no
no they did they wanted it digitized but
we're talking about a document of like
almost a thousand pages right so it
would take place
and um so you know i was kind of the
middle person doing this and i
i tried to explain to them that the you
know the assumptions that we have that
things should be completely open sourced
aren't shared by other people in other
places for various reasons and we we
just we are so arrogant that we don't
see that you know we're like
we should have that because of humanity
right well how do you know because you
know things that we take we're going to
use for our own benefit
you know so they're they're not seeing
it like we see it so that's that's my
advocacy for i mean i'm not going to
advocate for you know secrecy with
respect to almost everything but there
are if there's something secret there
are reasons that those people want it to
be secret
now i'm not saying that's a good thing
for everything you know but definitely i
mean
the vatican has their sacred documents
these are not necessarily secret
documents but they're theirs and they're
sacred to them
so we did establish uh we did get the
document um but i kind of am the person
who's the keeper of it and i can decide
who's you know i vet who see who goes in
and researches it and who doesn't and
you know what it's a document that's
written in latin and 17th century
italian and not a lot of people are able
to look at it
speaking of latin you mentioned that
tyler said
or sorry that you pointed out to tyler
that there was some latin written and it
couldn't this lecture you were giving
but the audio was not let's say it was
another highest quality for whatever
reason the person who was recording
didn't have a mic on you so the camera
is all the way at the back and anytime
the audience claps oh my gosh my ears
just
almost broke every single time because i
had to turn the volume up so loud to
hear you oh that's too bad between that
and the camera well anyway you mentioned
that
you were pointing out to tyler there's
some part of something written in latin
he said oh i didn't even know you also
mentioned it's to tell them quote
unquote that they dominate so i wasn't
sure who to them and they were referring
to so why don't you talk about that
please yeah okay so that was really
interesting so
uh one thing that was kind of funny
about my friendship with tyler was that
he was part of the space program he's
really integral into the space program
and he launches you know these rockets
and works with spacex and that type of
thing and what i found out which he
actually did not know and i pointed out
to him was that the whole thing was a
ritual the whole thing got was
ritualized so they identified certain
time periods astronomically when it
would be beneficial to launch and they
also had the rockets had
um roman gods on them
and they also had um latin first century
latin not medieval latin it wasn't
catholic latin it was basically
imperialistic latin
and so and everybody had to stay in
their own space like there was a place
where they had to stay they wore the
same clothes for every mission
um and they ate the same food i'm so
sorry to drop are you referring to a
spacex launch i missed that
yeah yeah well not all spacex launches
just certain of them with tyler involved
and so when he would be involved
launching these satellites into space a
lot of times they'd be with spacex
because that's who they used
yeah so they would they would go you
know they've been doing this from it
looks like from the 1950s onward they've
been doing this ritual and they would
even have like a chaplain there and you
know they would it was very very listen
it was very ritualized and so i noticed
that and i asked him about it and i said
do you know that this is first century
latin that's written on
these rockets and he said no i didn't
know that he didn't even know it was
aladdin and so we read them we i
translated them all and i said this wow
this says that and i said
who up there in space is going to be
reading this like why would you put that
on there you know that seems so strange
and he said well i imagine it's for them
and i said
okay who's who are they you know and so
he he just didn't say anything
but that's that's what it was
so the two questions that occur is
firstly what did it say and then also
does this mean that elon musk himself
is putting those messages there like
elon is a believer in et's and and so on
or is it just one of the staff members
no no this is beyond this is way before
elon so it has nothing to do with him
um his company is just the company that
puts those does the launches to get the
satellites up but he has nothing to do
with creating the satellites
or of putting the
roman stuff on them nothing at all to do
with that that that was definitely
predates him um so what does it mean
though um
yeah what was written on it yeah so to
me it looks like what i what people have
called like exo theology or
astrotheology it's this
this kind of well i call it it's not a
specific religion but it's a religiosity
of people who
are involved in the space program and
it's this um you know it's roman you
know the united states kind of considers
itself roman look at our you know
architecture and that type of thing
we're like the new imperial
place right and so i think that's what
it has to do with um they're using the
images of gods and goddesses from rome
um and what do the what does the latin
say
um here's a here's something for you to
check out
and it's the uh these that they're
called patches
and
have you seen those patches okay so haha
we don't know or ha ha but you don't
yeah uh-huh yeah and so a lot of those
are in latin and that's where you see
and a lot of those would be on the
actual satellites
the images would be on the satellites
and then people who were working the
mission they would get the patch
uh-huh and so the haha part was that on
the satellite or that was just on the
patch
um
usually you just have the god or goddess
and the image like the dragon or
something like that on the satellite
with the latin phrase that accompanies
it and the latin phrases are different
for each watch
you also mentioned there's a picture of
that that you were going to send to the
audience at that time because remember
i'm listening to the lecture and you
said yeah if anyone's interested i'll
email it to you can you email it to me
so i can place it on screen right now
for not right now sorry when i'm editing
this i'll make a note to remind you of
that is that okay yeah i could get it
right now if you want
the image is being displayed right now
so if you're listening to this on the
audio platforms then i recommend you
click the youtube link in the
description
what you're seeing is the high quality
capture unfortunately the source images
are fairly low
you also refer or not you someone
referred to the president as a short
timer okay what does that mean
yeah so um and i heard i'd heard this
from not just tyler but a lot of the
people who are part of the program
um that presidents are short timers in
the sense that there must be a program
that's not a short time program but a
long time program and therefore the
presidents come and go and therefore
they're not given the information think
of tyler tyler's been doing this since
he was at least 20 years old
and now he's in his 60s i mean that he's
a long-timer and so he has a lot of
information
and the presidents don't have all that
information they're only given the
information that they need to know
i know that we've mentioned tyler's
pseudonym plenty and i don't think
everyone here knows who tyler is or what
the story is around tyler so do mine
quickly just outlining that so that
people can
re-watch and say okay now that makes
sense i didn't give the context to sure
sure okay so i wrote this book i called
it american cosmic in reference to
um the russian cosmists because to me
russian cosmos is a great book for any
of our listeners um
um
by i think it's henry young
and
it's about the belief systems of the
people who started their the russian
space program and so when i started
american cosmic and i met tyler
he had a very similar belief system and
tyler was this person who actually
reached out to me
and he was part of a
secret program now they're not they're
known not to be secret and he had
clearances and that sort of thing and he
worked for every almost every space
shuttle launch okay he's a mission
controller
and um he's a very fascinating person um
i kind of kept him at a distance for
about a year and a half before i
actually met him in person
and then he took me and gary nolan to
new mexico to an alleged crash site for
ufos because he told me that ufo's from
the 1940s he told me that i didn't
believe in ufos and he said you only
believe in them as kind of like
imaginary things he said what if i
showed you evidence that and so this was
where i was like
automatically suspicious i was like wow
you know this is crazy but i'll go
um because you know it's still evidence
there's still data even if he's
disinformation it's still data so um
anyway so that's who tyler is tyler's
fascinating space program person
do you believe that the government
believes that they understand what's
going on behind the ufo phenomenon
no
so they realize that they don't know
what's going on or you think that they
think that they have a handle on it
i think that there's probably a number
of you know how in the united states we
have different we have democrats and
republicans and things like that i think
that the government is pretty much the
space program is like that there's
different factions within it and some of
them
are tasked with trying to figure this
out and some of them think they know
what it is about and some of them know
well we don't know what this is about so
that's how i think it really is just
compartmentalized and that's why i use a
lot of um i use a lot of references to
this movie and book called fight club
and it's basically about it this person
well
probably your audience knows but there's
that's what it looks like so before was
the invisible college where people
worked together who were scientists and
they were secret and they're trying to
figure out the stuff on their cover of
secrecy but then it morphed into i think
in the late 80s and early 90s it morphed
into fight club where people didn't even
tell each other what they knew in order
to keep the secret
secrets
do you believe that we're dealing with
multiple phenomenon that have different
explanations rather than a single one
yeah
definitely
so why do you think that
because they look very different so orbs
look different than tic tacs which
i don't even know if they are
extraterrestrial um and there are things
that like i could see from catholic
history from like you know 1400 1500
that look like john max abductions you
know and you can say wow that looks
exactly like you know could become it
could come out of john mack's book
uh
i think it's called abduction actually
um human encounters with aliens
so yeah those are different i mean i
think they're different i could be wrong
but they look different
have you seen this video one video i
believe called biblically accurate
angels yeah that's a i like that video
okay i'll link it or i'll even display
some of it here for people to watch now
does anything that you've learned about
the phenomenon ring true with those
depictions yeah yeah
i mean when you look yeah okay so if you
look at angels even you have to say
that even if you take this category of
thing called angels which we all think
we know what they are but if we go back
to the biblical text where they derive
from you'll see that none of those
encounters look the same
so even angels don't even look the same
to one another so you have so you have
angels that
take on the they look like humans and
they fight with like jacob and they
almost they dislocate his hip and things
like that and then you have these angels
that look very weird you know and scary
and then you look at saint francis you
know and his
uh situation with uh and it looks like
an angel they call it a seraphim right
and it like it it zaps him and he gets
these these things which the catholic
church calls stigmata but they look like
burns right and you know yeah so i mean
once you start to get to the primary
source materials of these things they
look very strange and they don't look at
all like what we have you know what has
come down to us as
what they're supposed to be like
yeah they're not the huggies no babies
they're not on a cloud with a supple
behind and smiling creepily at you from
a distance and you know even the people
that had those experiences back in the
day never said that either like saint
teresa of avila she's a person who had
an experience and now it's made popular
in rome um bernini created statue called
the ecstasy of saint teresa and it's in
rome and you can see it
and it's a it's this beautiful statue of
saint teresa in ecstasy it looks like
with this little cherub like angel next
to her but if you actually read it if
you read the account of it which she
wrote
um she basically says
i don't know what thing this is i don't
know if it's an angel
and then she said all i know is that
usually i see angels in my mind as an
imagination and this one is real it's
actually fleshy and it's about three
feet tall and it's all in light and it
also has this long thing that has a dart
at the end
like kind of like a uh an arrow and it
like basically
sticks her with this arrow i mean that's
creepy and you know that's exactly what
she said about it and then you have this
beautiful statue that doesn't look
anything like the very strange scary
narrative
remember i mentioned that lecture where
i couldn't quite hear all of what was
being said i believe you mentioned that
you were studying physical evidence of
purgatory a burnt hand i believe i'm not
right yeah yeah can you elaborate on
that and then also perhaps the physical
evidence of heaven
okay so the physical evidence of
purgatory i'm not saying it's actually
physical evidence of purgatory what i'm
saying is that people have this is what
the belief structure is is that you know
in order to create
belief in purgatory there was a priest
in the 1800s in france who decided what
he needed to do
was collect as much evidence for
purgatory as he could
so he went around all of europe and he
gathered this and now it's in a museum
called the purgatory museum in rome and
you can actually go online and check it
out okay and what this museum is i mean
a lot of it doesn't look like like good
evidence to me let's put it that way i'm
not convinced but
it's what people believe to be evidence
of burning souls in purgatory like a
hand on a bible and you see the kind of
the the burnt print handprint on the
bible and things like that so i don't
think that i mean you know so when we
look at so let's take and let's use this
as an example of doing religious studies
so you take that and you say okay the
impetus to try to prove something that
we cannot see i've even said this before
in a lecture
it looks a lot like what's going on with
ufo communities right now so the ufo
community in the united states is trying
to prove that ufos exist by taking this
debris that strangely enough i was
partially responsible for you know
getting
and at least for some of it and now
they're doing analysis on it when i say
they i'm talking about scientists
affiliated with these programs
and they're saying yes we have this well
i would be really careful with readily
believing that
because first you really want to really
really believe it i think a lot of
people really want to believe it and i
don't know why but there's that it's
very similar to what was going on in the
1800s with trying to prove purgatory was
real right
i don't think it's going to age well
right there what you're
doing with this book too it's also is
finding the similarities between
religion and then the ufo
phenomenon or you or ufology and so on
and so
one of the advantages of calling some
field
by some other field's name is that you
can use the old fields tools to
investigate the new field essentially
what i'm asking is what does calling
ufos or ufology or whatever it may be
we're just calling it religion
quote-unquote allow that wasn't there
before
i can give you an example
no you can give an example those are
always okay so let's say there's some
class of objects or people or practices
like veganism or architecture or car
driving let's just take architecture if
i was to say architecture is mathematics
that opens up that's uh maybe three
aspects so one would be
you can now use mathematical tools to
analyze architecture and then the number
two would be the vice versa so you can
now use architecture to help
innovations in math and then number
three would be
to
this is more of a social effect it would
have it would elevate or depreciate
the the field that's being compared so
in this case it may be a neutral to
positive result
so people would now view architecture
either the same or a bit more positively
because the general public has a neutral
to positive view of mathematics however
if i was to make a comparison to say
architecture's like garbage well then
that would depreciate people's view of
architecture
okay so
calling something by something else's
name
it has certain advantages it allows for
something so what does
calling ufos or ufology religion allow
for that wasn't there before
okay that's a great question and i don't
think i'm making that move actually what
i'm doing and i said i do this by
calling the book
uh american cosmic religion technology
and ufos right and i hold those three
things together
in
they simultaneously
engage each other okay so i'm doing i
think i'm doing two things i'm using
religion the tools of religion to study
the development of belief in ufos and i
think that that's a good thing to do
because
people in religious studies we don't
have to say ufos exist or don't exist we
can study it as a belief system okay
but i'm also using ufos as a way to push
the method methodological boundaries of
religious studies because religious
studies like that's interesting yeah
because religious studies likes to
reduce things just to social effects and
what i'm saying here is
we have a belief system that is now
corroborating itself through science and
that is something we've never seen
before no other belief no other religion
um christianity
islam buddhism no other religion has
actually said we are scient we can
corroborate ourselves through science
right but
ufology has or is doing it at this
moment in time and that's what i'm
saying to religious studies i'm saying
maybe we should take a look at this
because this is really interesting you
know and i wish more people actually
more people are now that you know the
the pentagon report came out in 2021 and
a lot of people in my field are looking
at ufos in a completely different way
now and um
so i feel pretty good about that
and
also you're not trying to dismiss or
make people disregard
ufos by labeling them as religion
because you have a nuanced view of
religion coming from religious studies
the reason i'm making that clear is that
when some people say well ai will kill
us and then someone else can say that's
like religion because the ai is like the
devil or vaccine hesitancy or acceptance
is that's like religion or whichever
route you want to take that usually is a
way of dismissing it saying yeah that's
just another religion but you're not the
suggestion under the underneath by this
it's implicit that it's it's it's simply
not true look the ai is not like a devil
so i'm calling it a religion to dismiss
people who are being a bit hysterical
about that and and so on so you're
not calling it religion in order to get
people to dismiss it
no no no i would no i would never do
that i wouldn't call religion that in
order to get people to dismiss it
because it's not so i think people draw
men
yeah yeah and i think you know in my
field
there's a lot of work to do let's put it
that way because people have so many
misconceptions about religion you know
there's a i'm constantly doing that work
and it will never be done
it's like unending
who's the modern day heidegger who's
furthering heidegger's work
gosh let me think
um
i know there's object-oriented ontology
but i don't know
is that it
um
i don't know if that is it um
like social ontology is that what you're
talking about
no it's harman's work i don't remember
his name but no people i'm always
wondering like what are the modern what
are some examples of these modern
philosophers like a contour heidegger
i'm trying to think of some modern
philosophers whose
work has
um i mean she's not modern in the sense
that her work was in the 70s but iris
murdoch's work
i think is really interesting
um
from a heidigarian perspective because
it seems to me that she's also going
back to a socratic
like understanding
of
basically inputting mysticism within
questioning
and she's also talking about moral
realism
so there are things that are actually
morally objective yeah that's that's
that's an unpopular opinion yeah it is
very unpopular but i'm attracted to it
right now
great well i happen to like the
unpopular opinions personally i find
them more interesting i think that i'm i
just pretty much play the counter
position
which is not great because it means my
views aren't mine mine are just counter
of whatever exists but i
i'm just so attracted to
to feeling like what's happening is not
correct especially the people who
adamantly say that their belief is
correct i just think how do you know how
do you know and it
it
it nettles me it bothers me inside
me too
so what was carl jung's opinions on ufos
i know he had a whole book on ufos
he did yeah um
i forgot the name of it but it has
flying saucers in the oh it's called the
modern flying saucers the modern myth in
the sky
okay
and um his views changed so at first he
viewed this as
uh he viewed ufos as an archetype like
this new archetype that he was figuring
out
but then he met a lot of people in the
government who actually had physical
they showed him radar reports and things
like that and so then he was like wow
and then he had friends who he found to
be credible tell him about their own
experiences of seeing ufos so then he
started to realize that this
idea of an archetype actually had a
physical component to it
and then the last thing you wrote about
it was a letter where he basically said
i think he honestly didn't know kurt
because i i mean if you read it because
i tried to read everything that i could
possibly get when i was writing american
cosmic that carl jung said about ufos
and what i came up with was that he
changed his mind a couple of different
times but the last thing he thought was
that
and i think you could see it in this
letter and i think i've it somewhere in
my book is basically
yeah he says it's an archetype but it's
an archetype that has physical qualities
to it which i thought was really weird
yeah
that makes it unexampled in the
pantheon of archetypes yeah so physical
component and so much as well they are
physical and so much as they interact
with ourselves and we interact with the
physical world but not themselves
yes so this is interesting so let's talk
about this for a second okay so
right now i'm looking at um there's a
person and again i will have to send you
because i like to give credit where
credit's due but unfortunately i read so
much stuff i forget the names of people
but this is a person who calls himself
a story technologist so he does like
he's a tech he says that um he does the
history of stories and he looks he uses
basically tons and tons of data just to
sh break down different stories and to
show how they actually
like what they do to our brains okay
and i'll send you a link to his work but
what i think is really interesting is i
agree with him that there was a point in
time when writing became a technology
right and so with writing stories were
able to be written down and so people
like plato and socrates said well
there's a new technology and like
aristotle did an analysis of the
technology of stories and he said these
are you know in a sense that's what carl
jung was doing when he was talking about
archetypes so he's talking about kind of
the elements that create these stories
that get told from culture and culture
again and again and again like the
hero's journey okay so this kind of this
mythine you know um
what did you call it
yeah that's levi strauss called it a
mithim it wasn't a myth because it was
more than a myth it was actually the the
very unit that created the different
myths right uh-huh okay so all right so
if i'm looking at stories as technology
when i went back to american cosmic and
in order to to try to push the method in
my field i had to embody and inhabit
what i called a myth which was the myth
of prometheus i had to actually live it
and i was super uncomfortable doing that
and then after that what happened was
in my next book i've morphed into a new
myth
embodying inhabiting a new myth and that
myth is basically the allegory of the
cave which is by the way not called an
allegory that was a later imputation so
this idea of the cave which by the way
we see it again and again and again with
like the truman show or the matrix you
know it gets played out in so many
different ways in our culture right now
um that we live in a simulation the
simulation hypothesis is basically
another iteration of this mythine okay
yeah so that's the that's the next
that's what i it's almost as if i had to
go through the promethean myth in order
to get to the allegory of the cave myth
and inhabit that and understand it
in order to
write about it
does this mean that you've managed to
get out of the cave what do you mean
when you say you're living that myth
yeah okay so
i feel like after i wrote american
cosmic you know in the myth do you know
the myth
so my understanding of the cave
myth allegory whatever one wants to call
it is that there are a set of people and
they're tied up and they're looking at
the wall and on the wall are images
which are atomizations because they're
shadows from something else well we
don't know that they don't know that
they mistaken the wall the cave wall for
quote-unquote reality until one gets
loose and then sees that
these are mere projections of something
else and this outside world is the true
quote-unquote reality
and
then people have forgotten about the
third part which is that the sun was too
blinding
and
they have to retreat into the darkness
essentially that there exists such a
thing as too much
truth
and also that they tell people and many
people consider them to be
de-cerebrate and insensate much like
right now with people considering those
who
well if you have any belief that is
borderline quote-unquote woo
then
that's what one is
labeled yeah so okay so this is that's
generally good good job okay so
there are two things though that i think
that we have to concentrate on
when i finished american cosmic i was
like kind of obsessed with the k the
cave and so i went back and i read
different versions of it you know
translations and everything which then i
realized wait a minute it's not actually
an allegory and wait a minute it's in a
book about politics
and so i thought this is strange and i
also thought this
i thought who are the people that tie us
up you know because and i asked a lot of
my friends if you happen to be
philosophers i said have you ever
thought about the people who tied us up
in the cave and they said oh no no no
it's just an allegory and i was like i
don't think so i think that people
actually tied us off
and in fact because of my experience
with american cosmic i believe that
people tied us up right and so i then
have wanted to tell people
yeah i think that people tied us up i
mean in the cave people tied us up i
know what i'm saying is you believe now
that people tied us up or yeah or yeah
indicating that the extraterrestrials or
whatever no no no i think that we're
doing it for each other we're you know
we're misinforming each other like
there's obviously this misinformation
campaign that happens for ufos let's
just say that happened we know it
happened yeah so people intentionally
said this is what's happening over here
what you see is real but all of a sudden
we're like whoa what i saw wasn't real
and we and so okay so i became kind of
obsessed with that and trying to get my
friends who are in philosophy to admit
that people tied us up
and then i read it so many times that i
realized that i was that person who is
basically trying to convince people and
that what happens is you have to
basically just leave the cave
and but there's something at the end of
the that uh the cave allegory i'm just
going to call an allegory since people
have called it that but it's not um at
the end that person who escapes the cave
and then goes back and tries to tell
people that they're in the cave and then
they don't believe that person and then
a person spends a lot of time
you know precious time basically saying
get out of the cave come on i'll help
you but they don't and they think you're
crazy and i thought people think i'm
crazy and i said i'm just gonna stop
because that's who i am in this right
now in this in this myth i am that crazy
person he's basically telling people
we got tied up everyone let's get out of
the cave well the the next step
is is what my book is going to be about
the next step is the step
of where that person leaves the cave and
then what they do
because they don't just leave the cave
kurt they actually engage in something
and plato calls it a craft or socrates
does plato's the one who's writing it
but socrates calls it a craft not a not
a
flying saucer craft a craft right like a
a way of being
that you engage in with another
and i think that's what i think that's
the heart of it and that's what we
forgot
like we've been kind of hypnotized by
the we are in a cave thing
and we forgot really what he was trying
to tell us and so i'm going to go back
and and kind of
do a reading of that
let me recount it once more so they see
the shadows guy or girl comes out
notices
quote unquote reality comes back tries
to tell people
and they don't believe him or her then
this person
leaves to do a craft
what is meant by that
in the book i mean sorry not in your
book necessarily if you don't want to
give it away but in the allegory yeah
allegory yeah so that's the question
what is meant by that so that's i think
the the thing we need to ask so what
happens is that they go out of the cave
and then he's talking to
i think it's his brother right or his
brother-in-law or something so
in the you know when plato recounts it
socrates is talking to somebody and he
basically says and wouldn't it be the
case
that we engage in this
this dialogue or dialectic
and that this is a craft and that we
this is what we need to do it's almost
like if you want to know the answer for
how to stay out of the cave or the
answer to help you you know
to deal with the reality that we live in
is to engage in this craft
and that's what he's trying to tell us
and this happens to be in a book about
political philosophy
and i think that's really important
and i think that iris murdoch's book
called um
i think it's called the good
um
it's something to do with the good i
just read it
but it's an excellent um it's an
excellent take on this i think she gets
it right
and the take is
that the good is to be political
i know the good is to engage in this
type of um
craft that that plato discusses and it's
an answer to the political
because you know in this talk you and i
have been talking about religion
democracy secularism you know we've been
talking about these different forms of
government and stuff and plato's
basically showing us something
and then heidegger believe it or not
gives back
and he tries to recreate that through
writing this philosophy where he
questions everything
and so he's basically doing exactly the
craft
although i don't think he actually gets
it as much as iris murdock does
that so that's what's happening and
that's what our that's what our culture
right now we're stuck in the cave and we
just don't we just don't know how to get
out and i think that that's it because
it took me i mean it took me a while to
figure it out myself like what is he
saying
and then i had to read it you know how
you can read something so many times and
then finally you're like oh that's what
he's saying right
sometimes it takes a while to because
we've been so
programmed to read it a certain way but
actually i don't think that's the way
it's meant to be read at all the way
that we've been reading it
i was watching a talk of john verveigh's
on heidegger and john was saying in his
language so i'm going to use
this is a bit esoteric but he was saying
that heidegger was stating that the
whole process of metaphysics for the
past 2000 years is one of distancing we
distance ourselves from the
as a subject from the object and
this is perhaps a misframing and that we
shouldn't be seeking propositional
answers but instead participatory
answers so that is
that
it's a difficult
i don't know how to
okay let me think
so a a dance is participatory so there's
a form of knowledge associated with
dancing that's not propositional it's
not writing and then it's not logical
for safe 100
well that's procedural as well so
there's another form of so are you
suggesting that
perhaps what's happened is that we've
gotten lost
thinking that the by elevating the
propositional knowledge and then what we
need to do is go back to the
participatory yeah and and that's
exactly what i'm saying i am exactly
saying that the way that we've read the
cave right
has been a propositional framework we've
used a propositional framework to read
it
and we've neglected to see the most
important point that is trying to tell
us
and that we have to go back
and look at that and really engage with
what it is that he that he told us back
in the day
and i think that heidelberg tried to do
that
i don't i mean he he was successful but
i think that a lot of people just don't
even know understand what heidegger was
doing and i think what you just said was
correct i think we have to be
participatory in that way
engage because the craft isn't engaging
it's a dialectic it's a dialogue
and you do it with a person and you know
what i find fascinating is that you also
see this in buddhism
so what there are these these things
called the three jewels of buddhism one
is the buddha not that you worship this
guy named the buddha it's actually a
title which means awake
and buddhism so you have buddha as the
as an example of what a human being can
become they can become awake
and then you have the dharma which is
the teaching and it doesn't have to be a
book it's anything that's going to wake
you up that's the teaching and then you
have the most important point the sangha
and that's the community because human
beings live together we don't live as
you know so we have to do this together
and i think that that's what socrates
was basically saying saying
they're all
in the cave like we you know okay sad
for them you tried to get them out
but now we have each other
and this is what we have to do to keep
each other from being put back in the
cave i mean he was saying that
and he demonstrated it in the book
is there an aspect of meaning associated
with this or rediscovering meaning
yeah
it's a it's a meaning that's intrinsic
now here's the reason i say that it's
because from my understanding of
heidegger and heidegger is one of the
hardest people to read yeah i agree he
makes up his own language
but he was saying look what a lover does
as a if you love your spouse you give
them flowers
you don't give them plants
you don't give them
the subjects of
of horticultural investigations
but they're the same
they're actually the same the path in
the flower and the horticultural
investigatory object is the same however
it's wrong to give your spouse a a plant
for valentine's day
and so it's because even though the
literal is the same the meaning isn't
and there's something about recapturing
meaning or looking at something in the
correct way that heidegger was pointing
to
one of the reasons i like heidegger is
that
in some sense remember i was giving you
an outline of what theories of
everything is
now no way am i saying it's a
continuation of heidegger's project but
it's it's similarly themed in that
he
was suggesting that the
that a project should be that we should
be understanding
our being in order to understand our
relationship to being in order to
understand being and while what is being
well being is
i i don't know how to describe what
heidegger would say being is other than
existence and earlier you mentioned that
heidegger was interested in why
something exists i think that
wittgenstein was interested in why
something exists and how something
exists where heidegger was interested in
existence what is existence itself i
agree with you i think so i think also
that wittgenstein realized that language
actually couldn't
contain a lot of what existence is about
and then you know he kind of gave up on
it he said
i think his famous quote is of that
which we cannot speak we should remain
silent which i of course don't agree
with because then you have art right and
music so let's not remain silent that
would take away a good part of what
living is about so
yeah
well he also was an artist he i don't
know if he meant language per se rather
than art maybe art wasn't it was a
was all right to
as a mode of expressing oneself to
understand the world it's strange
because i was looking up heidegger and
heidegger apparently was an atheist but
i see him as in a sense wrestling with
god or trying to figure out what god is
and same with wittgenstein
witkinstein i don't think he explicitly
called himself an atheist but either way
norman malcolm i don't know if you know
this his friend norman malcolm said the
religiosity that characterized
wittgenstein was greater than the
average religious person and
wittgenstein he said he can't help but
see every problem through religious
point of view so i see heidegger
similarly or even though he may say he's
an atheist it seems like what he's doing
is is trying to understand god
well i mean there's a reason why i'm
very attracted to his work and
you know and i i find it to be mystical
i think that his later work was he he
had a mystical experience and they tried
to
express that that understanding through
his and i think that's why he went
pre-socratic he went back to you know
socrates and
pre-socratics in order to
you know to express what he thought we
had lost as a culture
have you heard from many of the people
who are on the more buddhist slash
eastern end that would say that you
cannot discover god or
reality or whatever synonym one wants to
give it that has some dramatic flair to
it
you cannot discover it via an analytical
approach that you must experience it has
to be something that is beyond language
do you
have firstly have you heard that and
then secondly if you have do you believe
that to be the case
yes so i would say that um beyond
heidegger's writing and on a hannah
arendt's writing um i was very
influenced by the writings of the people
involved in what's called the kyoto
school
so the kyoto school was a japanese
school of zen buddhism philosophers they
didn't call themselves religious
religion wasn't even a term for them but
they they were using zen in order to
explicate like philosophy and that's how
heidegger kind of got involved with them
and um one of my
one of the books that i think is most
fascinating i think it's called um
i think it's called the philosophy of
nothingness
and i forgot exactly who wrote it but
it's that person his he has that's where
he links he actually went back and read
nietzsche and kind of through the lens
of zen buddhism and i thought it was a
fascinating book um so if you're
interested
it's the philosophy of nothingness
so yes absolutely that's what he's
basically saying i mean i also think
that nietzsche was a mystic as well you
know his his his flash is is basically
mysticism
now nietzsche is someone that i feel
horrible for not liking because everyone
likes yeah
but i don't i i just can't i'd rather
read what other people have said about
him than he then go to the primary
source which is anathema to
to scholars because it's well to me the
way that i view it it's like wine you
you
i for me when i drank which i don't
drink anymore but i was never partial to
wine to wine i
i i'll have some of it but then the same
with the stronger drinks they don't
taste good but i'm not going to torture
myself
by constantly drinking it in order to
get the quote-unquote in acquired taste
so i think that's what's necessary in
order to understand nietzsche properly
no it's not did did you not read about
my nietzsche synchronicity that cause
because i hated it yeah yeah well well
good for you in the sense that you're
lucky that you have that no i know
because i would have continued to hate
nietzsche as well just like you and good
for you i i would be very suspicious of
a person who naturally liked each other
frankly i think you have to encounter
nietzsche
so yeah i mean a lot of what he says is
horrible
so i'm much more of a lovecraftian in
the sense that you mentioned the cave
allegory and i'm much more inclined to
feel like that
and i used to be of the type that give
me the truth and no matter what form it
comes but i've had some experiences
where
i feel like sometimes the truth is far
too much for you to handle and you can
you can damage yourself
drastically from
an encounter with the truth and
lovecraft had this
this quote which which to me i interpret
as the case for ignorance
and it's it's something like the
greatest mercy in the world is the
inability for the human mind to
correlate its contents
and that
one day we'll see that this
unfettered scientific investigation may
bring about such a terrifying vista of
reality that we'll see
our fragile place in it and be so
frightened that we'll either go mad from
the revelation or
or flee from the light into the
peace and security of the dark ages
so
in the cave allegory i see that as the
person who runs back in the cave
now you mentioned that there may be a
solution to that and i well i'm i'm
praying and i'm hoping that your book
provides some solution to that because
right now i'm fleeing from the
from the
from the light let's say
you mean you're going back into the cave
i i it's yes i i wish and i i hope when
i pray for the for the cave i think that
the the more fiendish and cursed aspects
of a quote-unquote open mind haven't
been explicated by people or even
recognized that it's seen in this
culture as something that one everyone
should have more of and i think that my
mind has been somewhat
too open and i need to close it and it's
not pleasant to have such an open mind
and you know i'm not saying that as
something yet
yeah that's where the sangha comes in
that's where you have to have people
that help you
because it's not it's not easy to have
an open mind especially when everyone
around us is you know like they are
and that's why
i mean that's why it's necessary it's
not just
something helpful it's
necessary well
well
i
i'm very much looking forward to reading
that book do you have a title
right now i'm calling it the resurrected
because it's it's you know it's people
that have gone through
death in a sense
and are now alive again
and so i thought
that's
they're resurrected
yeah
have you gone through
well what's the difference between
epistemic shock and ontological shock
okay so i think that epistemic shock is
when you realize that the world you
thought you knew and the assumptions
that you had about it were wrong and
that
instigates probably ontological shock
where
it's ontological in the sense that
you can no longer live the same
like you know the ways in which you live
now have to change
so i see them as happening at
one right after the other
one is kind of theoretical and the other
is institutional
well okay to to make a play on words
there i feel like i have gone through
somewhat of each of those shocks and
have almost been to the point where i
need to be institutionalized and so it's
it's actually extremely frightening to
study consciousness and what reality is
and to constantly have
one's
world view
shattered
and
and and some and even do so for a living
which is what this channel is it's it's
not a
it's not pleasant
and
well it's not pleasant luckily i'm like
just getting out of it it's only
by the grace of god
just getting out of it but
it's not pleasant
i'm i'm wondering what was your
epistemic and ontological shock
specifically was there a moment
yes um it happened in i think it was
2012
and it was during the whole weekend
and it was just after the you know that
i think it was in march that the tsunami
happened in 2011.
and that was shocking of course
but after that i had a very
very real sense of impending
you know this could happen and it's
terrible like a whole civilization could
like get washed out or you know
something could happen and
apocalyptic kind of feelings and that's
when i was doing the research that i was
doing into the ufo
realities
and that's when i i went back and i
looked at some of the primary source
material for catholic history and i
realized what was happening
was happening now
and that people and that and that's when
i met people who
seemed to care
that i knew and that's those were like
you know the people we referred to
earlier and i guess the reality of this
shocked me on a level that that i call
it
pre-ufo diana and post-ufo diana right
okay and it definitely wasn't pleasant
so it was um and it lasted it was for
the weekend it was so
destabilizing
great work
yeah so i was destabilized so
but
i had a lot to fall back on
because i'd studied religion my whole
life
so i knew from buddhism and from
catholicism that there were
you know there are ways to get through
this because i read it you know it's
called
saint john of the cross calls it the
dark knight of the soul okay oh you know
you wanna oh sorry sorry just as a quick
sight i was being interviewed by someone
telling them about my experience and
they said curtis sounds like you're
going through the dark night of the soul
yeah that's what you that's what it is
it's the dark night of the soul so okay
so think about it now i've had i've read
all of this and knew all of these things
so i already had something to fall back
on which is why you don't
but you know nietzsche comes in handy
here because nietzsche went through it
too i it almost seems like he didn't
survive it frankly because he was so he
didn't have a sangha it didn't seem like
and he didn't have
you know he didn't have the well
heidegger had the catholic tradition
which he was able to
you know he also had his friends at the
kyoto school you know
try going through satori experiences and
and stay stable right
so you know so he had like a lot of
people so i think that that's something
that we have to take into consideration
here is that i think you know stay away
from
like
gather around yourself some people who
have been through it so that they can
say
oh yeah
been there you know what i mean so like
i get it you know so you need a sangha
so um
so that's what i had i had um i had i
have a woman named sister rose
so she's a catholic uh ursuline sister
and
this is how she put it she said
diana she said
this is what's going on she said you've
and jeff kreipel has a book called
flipped
in which he talks exactly about this
he says you flip jeff cripel yeah he's
at rice university you should have him
on your show he's great
so he's a professor at rice university
and basically he went through the same
he was a he was in training to be a monk
and then
he
recognized that he couldn't be so he
became a professor of religion
and he had it he had some cool
experiences okay so um
but he knows what this is about instead
of just cisco rose sister said
we tend to think that the world is like
how we were brought up to believe and
then all of a sudden we have experiences
that show us that the world is actually
not like that at all and then we
sometimes we never get over that she
says
but
we're here like you know her order you
know and her and the catholic you know
the the people of the church you know
they had mystical experiences she said
this tradition is here to tell you that
we are in the world but we are not of
the world and that actually makes sense
now to me because i was like
ah that's what that means she said it's
really like the way you see it now
that's really how the world
looks but it's not like how these other
people see it she said they just think
that it's like that but they're not
actually you know it might happen to
them too at some point they might get
flipped she goes but mostly it probably
won't because it doesn't happen to
everyone it only happens to a few so
does that make sense so there are people
to which this has happened
and now they live in this reality and
that reality for them
is um
is the normal reality
what do you mean when you say it is the
world is actually how it looks
well when i say okay so you know when
you you've gone through a night of the
soul of the dark night of the soul and
the next day or you know when for me it
was that weekend
and then i was i said to myself okay
i have a new perspective on what life is
about
and
now i'm going to have to live with this
new perspective i don't know what it's
going to be like
and so that's what she was trying to
explain to me she was trying to explain
that
you you don't have to go back to the
perspectives and use those as tools for
interpreting the world she said
you're fresh it's like you're born again
you're new in this new world and now you
have to use different tools but
thankfully because i've been studying
about religion and philosophy my whole
life i had all those tools
but i just didn't know that that's what
i was doing my whole life i was
preparing myself to kind of do that by
use by learning those tools and now like
i have a lot of people who come to me
who are students or
you know who are grown-ups you know and
this has happened to them and they're
like what do i do and then i give them
you know say okay this is you know a lot
of times in their own tradition they'll
have a book that they just
they read but they forgot about
and then they'll go back and say oh
so people have gone through this
and this sangha i imagine that's a
community where people have similar
values what is it yeah so in the
buddhism um it's the sangha is the
community of people who are waking up
and helping each other stay awake
because buddhism is about waking up from
the illusion
yeah
so they're waking up so yeah exactly
that's where i am i want i i used to
envy people i don't i don't want to be
awake any longer and and you know
there's great research that says sleep
is helpful sleep is healthy sleep is
we're not sleeping enough i would like
to go back to sleep personally
i hear what you're saying yeah i
understand
but the sangha is there for you
when you go through the process of
awakening
they're there to help you out
and those are those are those are the
three things that you need in buddhism
okay so that's what i'm saying is like
buddhism
to me looks very similar to
the thing that socrates suggests we do
at the end of the cave
it's this is an engaging kind of thing
like what you said participatory
so it involves other people you can't do
it alone
i also find that
so you mentioned the song is awakened
people but i find that the more i
interact with people in general the more
i go out the more it's not just my wife
because i pretty much only interact with
her because
well for the past couple years because
of covid and the more that i see family
and
and talk to people at coffee shops and
so on and i'm friendly
the the more it well that drastically
helps me but they're not people who i
would
consider to be awakened per se i just
say they're people
so is is am i not doing it correctly
no no i mean i think you're doing it
correctly because i think in buddhism
too anything can be a teaching like
dharma is the teaching whatever kind of
helps you it could be circumstances it
could be events it doesn't have to be a
book it doesn't have to be a song or a
movie or a person talking to you i think
that being around people though i mean
we have been through a lot through kovid
and i think just getting out and talking
to people we're naturally
we're beings who who like to be around
people and then like to have our space
right so i think that's natural it's
kind of like
eating we need to eat so we definitely
need to be around people and i think
that covid is as maybe caused a lot of
us to
be in the cave too long or something
literally are you an introvert you would
consider yourself to be an introvert
definitely i'm an introvert yeah
but um but i'm a good i'm an introvert
that's learned how to be an extrovert
because of my job same same yeah yeah
yeah okay i'm gonna tell you this and
but i'm not gonna i'm gonna take this
off the record so what happened to me
was
i i had it it's at this point that i
suggest you watch the carl fristen
episode i consider that to be the most
important of all the theories of
everything videos mainly because it
serves as a cautionary tale
like mentioned in the beginning and also
because i don't like talking about this
experience and this may be the last time
that i do so so if you would like more
context then visit that link in the
description thank you and if you've
experienced something similar just know
that you're not alone
and that the more that people talk about
this sort of issue the less humiliation
and disrepute will be thrown around
because many many many more people have
experiences like this than you think
it's just that most people don't talk
about it at all because they're afraid
and being i i understand what it's like
to be afraid trust me either way you are
not alone
luckily i haven't had like i'm saying
luckily because i don't want any more
experiences like that that shattered me
i don't have the strength to go through
that or i think i don't have the
strength but anyway and hanging around
people and someone's helping so that's
an aside like jess we will take all of
that out but i just wanted you to know
that that's the context from where i'm
coming from i encourage that you hang
out with them those people because what
i found in my life too
was that a lot of the people that seemed
to understand how being
like really being
human and good were people that weren't
philosophers you know they were people
who were i was involved in a homeschool
group with my kids
and these were just catholics who
believed pretty straight up
not complicated catholicism right so i
wouldn't and never talk to them about
the stuff i'm talking to you about and
um
that was as that was good for me and
that was good for my kids
so um i think i'd go to church
and a lot of my friends who are
intellectuals think i'm crazy
but i go
and i think that these things these
simple things i think they're good
mm-hmm
that's the aspect of religion that
that it's
it's not valued enough in the
irreligious circles so they'll say yeah
well like if they're going to ascribe
any salutary component to religion they
would say well it promotes community
yeah that's a huge huge huge yes you
have no clue
yeah and that's why i say the sangha
it's one of the three things it's called
the three jewels of buddhism
they definitely understand it
it's community
and did you know that in catholicism
it's actually considered a sacrament
community
what's a sacrament meaning oh a
sacrament means it's a um it's imbued
with the power of god
so community like a church community is
imbued with the power of god so i feel
like i found that in lots of different
christian communities
okay we'll end on just a couple audience
questions and that's it about everything
okay sure i know they're like
30 40 50 100 but we'll just get to a
couple that are interesting so this one
comes from giuliano vargas virtually all
contactees say that aliens
that the aliens themselves believe in a
supreme creator god or being
now i don't know if that's necessarily
true but regardless that's the premise
of this question should we try to
reconcile our current religion with the
new knowledge with this new knowledge or
just seek to be spiritual by believing
in god and doing good deeds
um yeah so my personal opinion is that
since we don't know the first part of
his question we don't know that to be
factual
um i think that
um doing good deeds and having a
community of support
is what in my opinion is what we should
be doing i think that's good
okay how do you reconcile your catholic
views with the phenomenon and do you
struggle to keep faith when dealing with
something like
this phenomenon according to jack vale's
theories which acts like a quote-unquote
control system this question comes from
number two
sure yeah that's a great question so um
yeah it's only strengthened my faith so
i am um
i'm a you know i study religion
but i am also religious
but i always have been
and this has only
reinforced my faith
um
so the question is
i think the question that this person
asks
is
it and i've been asked this question by
many people by the way also people who
are part of congress have asked me
questions like this like um and
journalists like won't this shatter
the belief systems of religious people
and my my answer is not at all i talk on
catholic radio a lot
um like on the drew mariani show and
such
and
it seems to me and also being involved
with people at the vatican um that
christianity already has within it as
well as islam and as well as judaism
these at these three religions and if
you look at hinduism as well and
buddhism you know these are the
traditional religions um you'll see that
there's already categories there are
already categories for belief in
extraterrestrial beings and that you
know the the creed of the catholic
church basically says you know god is
creator of all that is visible and
invisible and in within that invisible
category
john paul ii said angels exist and you
know things like that so um i know a lot
of catholics like um if you look at um
would you baptize an extraterrestrial by
uh brother guy
and
father mueller you'll see that they say
they believe that if there are
extraterrestrials that they're created
by god
so it there's it's not an either or
position as i look at it there's no it's
not a question of either this or that i
think it's a both and questions
why do you think the hitchhiker effect
occurs
what have you heard
okay so the hitchhiker effect for those
who don't know is this idea that
they're around people who have these
experiences like say they see a lot of
orbs and they have
paranormal experiences and things like
that and that this is kind of a
contagious experience in that it'll
it'll go on it'll hitchhike onto a
person and head home with them um yeah
so i knew a lot of researchers who saw
this happen i've had friends who were
researchers who wouldn't go to places
considered hot places of um ufo activity
because they didn't want it to come home
with them um
what do i think about it i mean that's i
don't know
it's really strange um do i believe that
it's real definitely i mean it does i
have no clue what it is um that do i
think that is mental or objective i
can't tell you
but do i believe that actually happens i
know enough scientists who
will stay away from hot places because
of it yeah
so you mentioned that some of the people
who would have the hardest time or the
humanists i think you mentioned that
well you mentioned it here but i'm using
the word humanist right now christians
believe and they you can see this in the
comment section i'm sure you're aware of
considering the alien beings to be
angels or demons but i'm wondering is
there a third option no it's for sure
yeah like what else are there besides
angels and demons yeah so i mean we have
exo so people who are doing like looking
at habitable planets like exoplanets and
things like that you know these are
straight-up scientists who are doing
this work and they're out there just
finding out if there's habitable planets
or life out there even and i think that
that's the way to look at it i think
that that has nothing to do with the
idea of these are angels or demons we're
just looking for
potential
planets that have even moons or even
asteroids that have you know life on
them and i think that that's a
scientific endeavor and that has really
nothing to do with religion whatsoever
it just has to do with exploration you
know and that's what we're doing you
know we're kind of an exploratory
species and we're now heading out into
space and exploring that and that's the
third option
the two religions that come up plenty
when studying this phenomenon is
gnosticism so i don't know why
that gets mentioned simultaneously with
the phenomenon but i want to know what
your thoughts are and then raw
secretionism if i'm even pronouncing
that correctly yeah why yeah i don't
know what the second one is sure okay
raw secretionism so raw secretionism is
a mystical element um tradition within
christianity that is it's called the
holy cross the rosy cross okay
and rosicrucianism and so a lot of the
medical college people happen to be
um rosicrucians and in fact the term
invisible college comes from the history
of secretionism and so this is a
mystical tradition within
european history where you can identify
scientists who are also
alchemists who are also interested in
non-human intelligences and things like
that and getting in touch with angels
and entities so there's a whole history
of this and so that is one tradition
that a lot of people identify
with you you know people who are
involved in ufo research um the other
one is gnosticism and narcissism is kind
of like pre prior secretionism so there
were um there were jewish yeah so there
were jewish gnostics and then there were
christian gnostics so narcissism
basically is a greek word that means
gnosis it means knowledge
and it's knowledge of
it i always i explain this to my
students like this
um
so
uh michael jordan is an awesome
basketball player okay
he's he's gnostic with respect to
basketball okay
i know about the history of basketball
but i'm a terrible basketball player
therefore i have information about
basketball but i'm not gnostic about it
i don't have gnosis i don't have
knowledge of it like experiential
knowledge right so it's an internally
it's not narcissism is knowledge that
you have intimately right so after
baking
an apple pie
a hundred times you're going to be
gnostic about it
okay okay so that sounds like the
propositional versus the participatory
that we referenced earlier or is that
different that's exactly it yeah
so it's an in internal intrinsic
knowledge
um but you you develop it you might
start developing it propositionally but
then it becomes gnostic
it becomes participatory okay so it's
kind of like an ingredient you know uh
an agree uh not a
recipe
so there's a recipe for apple pie i'm
not a great baker so i need a recipe for
apple pie it's not gnostic i'm not a
gnostic baker but after i've made it a
hundred times i can get rid of the
recipe
see it says propositional to
participatory
um that's narcissism
narcissism is also there are different
forms of gnosticism um there was
christian gnosticism like i said in
jewish narcissism um and the christian
gnostics were like mary magdalene
and these were people who
believed that they had a
uh an understanding of jesus and of god
that was intrinsic and that they would
pass on to others and they also had
ideas of um
like other worldly beings and things
like that so gnosticism was a tradition
that and still around by the way there
is a gnostic christian church today and
so there's only one
i believe that there are many but okay i
know i know of one so okay but a lot of
people call themselves gnostic
and this relates to the phenomenon
i think that people well first of all
secretionism is relates to the
phenomenon because
um
a lot of the people in the invisible
college are in in some ways very
secretion like some of them are overtly
secretion so they're part of this this
tradition the invisible college itself
the name is rosicrucian it's a roast
secretion term
um so that's how it relates
it's also a mystic tradition which i
find interesting
is there any relationship between
kurzweil's technological singularity and
the omega point and uaps
okay um
wow that's a hard question okay so sure
done is
his omega point
is something that's also called the
newest fear
and the relationship is that
both
okay both kurzweil
and chardonn
are looking at
another kind of um atmosphere basically
that links actually all of us together
but it's a network and it's a network
that is
he calls it the newest fear it's it's a
biosphere it's kind of like a biosphere
but it's linked by it appears to me it's
linked somewhat telepathically or
it's like a neural network but there's
there's it's not it doesn't have a
platform like you know like digital
platform
it's a different sort of platform that
has formed on its own
um
biologically so
but it's it's a fascinating thing and if
you look at kurzweil's work too
especially the intro to singularity uh
that looks fairly spiritual you know he
talks about it as if he also has this
vision that's like a palpable vision
that he has so if you're if so if any of
your listeners are interested in that go
back and reread that first part the
first the introduction and the first
chapter of the singularity and it looks
to me similar to
books about this that have happened in
the past i mean it's very spiritual
let's put it that way um his the way
he's writing looks
um
it's fraught with kind of a spiritualism
to it
and how does this relate to ufos if at
all
okay so does it relate to ufos i think
that
no not necessarily i mean if you could
say that the kind of if you could look
at this from an evolutionary standpoint
such as carl jung does
um
and also in my opinion so does
uh chardon okay what you're looking at
is you're looking at kind of like a
a spiritual progression of humanity okay
so this is what they're they're saying
they're basically saying that we're
progressing into
um a new state of being human and it
includes this network it includes a
network in which we can communicate with
each other on a different level than the
way in which language is used it's a
different sort of language and does that
how does that correspond to ufos it so
happens to
be at simultaneous
with what we call kind of in the in the
20th century the flying saucer right so
we see these these kinds of things and
so you called this a new archetype right
the image of the fine saucer new
archetype so you can say that these kind
of happen at the same time and are they
related they're related in this way
they're related in the sense that there
is a a lot of people experience a
spiritual transformation when they they
encounter
or see ufos um
the
the singularity and the newest fear
are also conceived of as being spiritual
in nature as well okay so um part of the
people that i'm talking with
today
and are people who
believe that there is there are
different types of networks there's the
network that we call the
internet right the digital
infrastructure the internet of things
there's going to be a biological network
now that we're you know the internet of
things is actually somewhat of a
biological network as well because we
interact with it physiologically um
but then there's another network that's
separate from that and humans have been
on that network as well but they don't
identify it as such so
part of what i'm doing now is i'm kind
of like working out how people are
looking at this thing they called they
call a separate network than the network
that we hook into physically and
materially
you use the words
new when referring to jung and the
archetype that you consider ufos to be a
new archetype but my understanding of
archetypes is that there's a timeless
nature to them and that the
representations can be new
like we could all be orbiting the same
object and representing it differently
but the object itself that's trying to
be represented isn't new so did you
actually say that there was a new object
somehow
no he didn't necessarily what he said
was that this was a new um
he didn't even call it a religion he
called it a new myth
but not the myth you know not
the type of myth that we see when we say
oh greek myth or something like that
which basically are religions you know
if you look at greek myth that this was
religion for weeks back in that time
period so um
yeah so i think that is it new um it
doesn't look to be new um but the ways
in which humans engage with it i think
are new absolutely
i see nicely okay so what do you make of
the recent ufo hearings
yeah so i i i watched them and um
i found them to be interesting
i don't have a lot to say about them in
the sense that you know
the specifics you know do i think that's
you know we've moved ahead with them um
with the topic of ufos and things like
that
um i would look at it in the sense that
uh
um
here give me some time because i have
thought about this but of course now
i've blanked out on it i can't remember
what i was going to say
okay i'll give you something i'll give
you some time so do you want me to just
be silent while you think
yeah just give me some silent time to
like kind of um okay so um
all right
okay okay this is it all right
me looking at this okay looking at these
hearings um and based on my experience
of the last
few years well more than a few years
maybe six or seven years where in i
identified what i'd call like a fight
club
of people who are involved in you know
the study of uaps and ufos
and what i mean by fight club is i mean
that people these people are
compartmentalized and they don't talk to
one another
i can't see how a hearing a
congressional hearing is going to
pierce any of the information within
that fight club i think what's happening
is that there's a recognition that there
is this this group of people who do this
kind of study they probably you know
they're probably different factions in
fact there are different factions and
groups of them doing pretty high level
study of this stuff
but they're not talking to each other
okay
um they're not talking to each other
because that's how they've been trained
so so whereas you know we've already
talked you and i about academics and
this kind of academic ethos of sharing
our sources to further and progress
knowledge
okay this is this is actually a method
and we believe in it and we even believe
that this is right
okay well this is you know and for
better or worse it could be you know i
don't i now i was so surprised to hear
that
well i shouldn't have been surprised
the the fight club
um and the compartmentalization of these
groups is necessary for these groups to
further their knowledge okay
but it doesn't work in the same way that
we think democratic
progression of knowledge works does that
make sense it works differently it works
almost the opposite so when i see the
hearings i hear that
it's a very it's i i think i posted
something on twitter where i said this
isn't the valet
level of talking about the topic right
it's not gonna get that way it won't get
that way
maybe ever okay we can't expect it to so
for what it was
um
it was it was okay you know for what it
was it was okay it was something that
recognizes at least and modifies the
stigma that's been attached to
ufos for the past 50 years okay and
that's a good thing that's good for me
because i wrote about it
and it's good for other academics who
want to go in and and study it it's good
for people who've seen ufos and have
felt like they couldn't tell anyone
about it so it's good in that way okay
um but is it you know frankly i think
that the fight club
of compartmentalized people who study
this is going to continue probably get
more funding even now because of this
but that's what i see
as the consequence of this i don't think
i have um i i don't see these two groups
talking
yeah so it's not disclosure per se it's
more
the
creation of the environment that allows
disclosure slash research by removing
the stigma well research
remember research has already been
happening so um
i think it's removing the stigma and i
mean honestly i think that's that's a
good one
this one comes from tupac cabra who has
a twitter account that's oh link in the
description does the catholic church
have their own term slash practice slash
training for remote viewing and if so
does it predate the us governments and
how put offs
programmed a good question they actually
do
and if you it's not called remote
viewing um but it's called discernment
and so um
we've talked about people in the
invisible college a lot of them being
catholics i don't know if all of them
are but
most of them are
and so um one of those people is jacques
jacques valet
and when i first met him and throughout
my
collegial friendship with him
um
he's
said to use your discernment and this is
something that must be developed okay
and so that caused me
to recognize the term as being from the
catholic tradition because that's you
know obviously but something that we we
use a lot but we don't know what it
means and what you know what's the
context of this and catholic history so
you go back and you look at where this
develops and basically it's this
recognition that humans have the ability
of to see things that you can't you know
humans in general some humans have it
more than other humans to be able to see
or have information about
people or events
um that
you couldn't like get in a normal way
through the five senses or something
like that and that's called discernment
and
so yeah so i think that cultivating a
spiritual practice
is what
helps one
discern um the remote viewing community
gave specific instructions for how to
cultivate
uh the prac you know the ability of
remote viewing um in my opinion though
they left out
some of that the ways in which you can
not go crazy and do it at the same time
because i think there's a point where
you're gonna get a lot of information
that you don't quite understand
don't know how to deal with and you know
i think that spiritual traditions have
things in place to help people with that
um so
you know the catholic church has its own
you know internal group of you know if
these things start to happen to you
think this way in buddhism you have the
same thing if you start to see these
things or if you start to have you know
uh recognition of events that are going
to happen um ignore them or something
like that you see what i'm saying so
to utilize these talents for gain
material gain
or
for selfish reasons
um
i think that this is this is something
that
one in my personal opinion this is not
me speaking as a professor but in my
personal opinion i wouldn't really do
that
um
but that's how remote viewing in these
communities has been used not
necessarily for personal
gain but um
you know for
obviously
uh some corporations use it to assess
what other corporations are doing
um obviously if national security if
this was something that national
security would want to obviously
russians have been doing remote viewing
you know the americans have been doing
it as well
so yeah so
yeah so i think that you see this within
different religious traditions but the
contexts are different
and you know the
the
you know the desires for the
consequences are different as well
when i was speaking to this guy named
thomas campbell not on ufos in fact i
don't think he has an opinion on them as
far as i can tell but he has a theory
called my big toe quote-unquote
he said that people have the ability to
do remote viewing and i think you called
it by
location or the catholic yeah by
location
right which is some form of astral
projection and he said but it can only
be used for non-selfish purposes and
that if you wanted to win the lottery or
prove it to someone else which is a
strange
way of phrasing it because then it
sounds like it's unfalsifiable if what
you're doing is trying to bolster your
ego in some sense then it doesn't work
so you're saying that actually no there
are cases occur where
you're aware of or you believe to be the
case that some corporations have used it
for profit and
perhaps some nefarious purpose on parts
of some government
or no you're not saying that well no not
necessarily nefarious if it's for
national security i mean they're doing
it in order to gain you know information
to protect americans or
russians to protect russians i mean you
know that's their job so
they saw that this actually works so
they
tried to utilize it um ed may um who i
met at the rice conference uh the
archives of the impossible conference
had a great presentation on remote
viewing
and um
he would be the person to talk to but
yeah within the catholic church there is
something like that but it's it's
completely
devoid of this this use right and
also um i've seen kind of these kinds of
practices in buddhism as well but again
totally devoid of this type of
let's do
you know this let's do this for
to find out what our enemies think or
let's do this to find out what our
competitors think so we could get the
upper hand
i see okay so the last one was pretty
much just a like a personal question a
person for myself i've been lucky enough
on toe on the podcast to get some people
who have said no to virtually every
other place and i'm not sure why and jim
semivan said that
there's this sentiment behind the scenes
that toe is
a quote-unquote scientific podcast and
if one wants to talk about the
phenomenon in some technical manner then
perhaps it's the place to go i don't
know if i'd buy that because well for
various reasons but
some people
for example on reddit have called it
distoster like there's disclosure like
somehow
yeah right right maybe i'll make a merch
item of that
so
that is cool
is that something that could happen i'm
not saying that that has happened but
does that occur is there a
behind-the-scenes kind of um discourse
about them and um you know who's good to
go on and who's good not to go on and
that type of thing for
people who um talk about things that
are like ufos and things like that is
that what you're asking yeah um
yeah
right i think so
and um i think that um
i mean we talked about this when we
talked about you know if we're talking
about something like ufos and the you
know if in fact ufos are say
extraterrestrial um
or
if in fact they are non-human
intelligence okay that we just have not
discovered yet because you know whales
have non-human intelligence and such we
know about them okay but if this is some
kind of new form of non-human
intelligence
that is able to travel our skies
and um this would be something that
the military would absolutely want to
know about and so that makes discussion
of it
highly um
surveilled
okay
and
up for potential management therefore
podcasts um you'd have to assess use
your discernment and assess and vet you
know peoples whose people
or podcasters
um you know
what message are they putting out there
and do you want your work to align with
that message or not that kind of thing
so there's no i mean there's no real
kind of like um non-biased media even
podcasters have their biases so we so i
think that a lot of people who are at
least my colleagues who are working on
the topic of uaps and ufos generally are
academics or they're associated with
programs that have to do with academia
um or government programs and so they're
going to be pretty careful about where
they go to spread their information um
if they're people who've been doing this
for a very long period of time say like
jacques valet
um i think that his message is pretty
clear has been out there for a long time
so it can't be used or manipulated right
and i think that he's safe to go on
anybody's podcast frankly um but other
people whose work
is maybe different than valets and whose
work has not been out there for years um
i think they have to be pretty careful
if you were me what would you do to help
safeguard against being used for
disinformation
right so that's actually hard to do
i think that you have to be pretty clear
in your questions and you have to be
pretty clear
in
your intentions a lot of times you can't
control the people you're you know who
you have on as a guest
and
a lot of times you there are unintended
consequences of what you put out there
um like that happens to me so i'll have
i'll have said something and then it
will be used in a completely different
way
and there's really nothing we could do
about that crew so it's a public sphere
that you're putting this message out
in and then what happens is that beyond
your own intentions those things then
get completely changed and used
i've actually written about this but um
not specifically for ufos but definitely
for religion
um
you know the uh the raid
you know the monk the immolating monk um
quang duke i can't remember his full
name um but he's a vietnamese monk who
is or was
he was who emulated himself
um
you know during the vietnam war
or beli i believe maybe directly
afterwards well his image was then taken
up by this band called rage against the
machine and put on a cd cover of theirs
and then became the image kind of
came became
decontextualized from the actual reason
why this man actually did this was to
protest
um
suppression of buddhism by the
communists via the vietnamese government
and so um
so then people actually have tattoos of
it and about i'd say it was like maybe
12 years ago when my students had a
tattoo
and i said you know i said the name of
the monk
and
he said he didn't even know
he just thought it was a cool image but
he had tattooed on his body so i guess
my point is this is that you know
that man did this
important act for a very specific reason
but
but nobody knows about it now but his
image is out there we all we've all seen
the image you see what i'm saying yeah
it reminds me of teenagers who have the
shirt that has the nirvana logo and even
says nirvana and then you play them teen
spirit or smells like teen spirit and
you say who sings this to it i don't
know i've never heard this man before
that's pretty funny so the way that i
try to safeguard against it is firstly i
don't think i can and secondly is with
regard to intent i hope that this is the
case i don't consider myself to be
well i'm i'm a selfish person but
hopefully this is the case where i'm
just an extremely curious person and
much like yourself much like researchers
in general and so i have many questions
and when it comes to a physics person
i'll just say i have a professor here
and it's like office hours and so i'm
just saying i don't understand this part
how did you get from here to here how
does this make sense with this and then
they try and explain it to me and where
i don't understand i ask questions and
so i do something similar with the ufo
guests where i'm simply asking questions
but then i also feel like that's a
cop-out if i was to say
hey i ask questions and then it's up to
the audience to quote-unquote decide i
don't like that i think that when people
say that they're abdicating their
responsibility of putting out quality
information so i don't know how to solve
that
yeah i don't know if we can't solve that
like i said look what happened to
uh
the vietnamese bunks image
i think that's it i took up so much of
your time it's so generous
oh yeah
yeah thank you so much yeah thanks for
inviting me on your show
professor thank you so much for spending
maybe three hours at least with me it's
a blessing
absolutely it was wonderful to talk with
you thanks for inviting me
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you